are getting set for the semi-finals of
the speed chess championship Sergey
Karjakin vs. hit car Nakamura with me
here my co-host grandmaster robert hess
robert it hasn't been this close in
terms of predictions in and i think any
match we've had according to everybody
looking at this with with sergei Calkins
dominant performances and blitz can he
get a big enough lead to hold his ground
before it gets to bullet and the
greatest bullet player likely of all
time Hikaru Nakamura takes over your
thoughts sir on what goes down today
before the games get started in about 30
seconds
yeah I was very surprised by how even
the pregame kind of estimations were I
think that Hikaru is the favorite in the
bullet portion but he might be in the
longer time which shows he actually held
his own in the bullet as well so I think
that story cardiac of the world blitz
champion will give a card Nakamura huge
test today all right well the players
are here they are ready and we are
getting set for this show to get
underway and on that note we have
liftoff with everything getting
up-to-date here all right Robert
here we go our first game we have a
London your thoughts well it's what I
chose in my gaming in against the world
right now so I have to support it and I
think that cardiac it is just he's
opting for something a little more quiet
some of the he can play quickly and in
general I feel like the London is not
the easiest opening to fully equalize
against it has not the best reputation
as kind of being a wimpy opening but I
think that given is the first game of
the match and they're just feeling each
other out
I like the opening choice by Kraken yeah
well we saw him play it and employ it
pretty successfully in both of his
matches so far that being that being the
London so no reason to fix it if it
isn't broken right and but this is
already getting into something a little
strange and unique here with the early
night h5 the Bishop popping back and
white opting for a fee and keto here on
the on the Kings side with g3 is this a
typical approach here or is this really
just a result of Hikaru playing the
knight h5 line which forced this bishop
away from the typical London Square well
it certainly makes sense in the fact
that
crickets sit on c7 but this idea with f5
the e5 square will permanently be weak
so look at Kuryakin already throwing his
name into the center and now you've a
couple options you can go Bishop b5
trying to trade off the light square
bishop for the night it looks weird
because you've already started the
fianchetto option on the King side but
you know cementing that c5 square for
the knight is often very important but
also just Knight d2 f3s was just played
makes a lot of sense because it's gonna
be very difficult for blacks even if say
the Knights get traded you black will
never want to go east 65 himself because
that leaves him with a nice lady plan so
white has the spatial advantage in the
better position in the early going here
yeah and the the question is already
being brought to the knight if white
tries to keep the knight on e5 with
Bishop before does black go right back
to this Knight h5 plan which I think for
some players immediately looks like oh
we don't put pieces on the edge but hey
you have to find a way to loosen White's
grip on the dark squares here even at
the cost of a lost time but okay I guess
Sergei answers that and says I'm not
even gonna over protect it I'll retreat
the night this is based on the idea you
said right he's not really worried about
her Carter breaking e5 because of the
positional weaknesses that are gonna
happen to this d5 pawn right and it's
actually kind of like a stone wall type
of position right with the pawns an f5 e
six and d5 and that often favors white
strategically and the big difference is
that there's been a set up on straight
at the C pawn for black for the e pawn
for white and yes black can sit this
knight on e4 for now but sooner or later
White's gonna go move the knight on f3
and go f3 himself and that kicks that
night away from the center so for the
time being I think that black is doing
okay and I would consider playing move
like Bishop takes d3 and was just played
because the e5 square is a very
important one and so now black actually
can start trying to think about going f4
right now I'm not right away that that
weakens the protection on the e4 Knights
I wouldn't rush that at some point
opening up that F file could be
dangerous for white okay great
so if the if the knight so here white
has two choices right try to move the
knight and go for this sort of typical
plan to undermine this pony here or is
there some other drawback to that mainly
because if you move a piece away from
the Kings side like you said maybe then
f4 becomes a real opportunity for black
although Knight - D - perhaps is the
is the idea for white which would
prevent it for a given that it brings
more attackers to e4 plus if we if one
of the typical ideas in this structure
obviously if you can trade the piece
that's currently closing the e-file
that's gonna open up pressure for whites
work on e1 to go after that long term
positional weakness on e6 so I'm
expecting 92 at some point here from
Kuryakyn yeah 92 makes a lot of sense I
think that and as I must say a 4 makes a
lot of sense and the key difference here
is that white can sort of initiate pawn
breaks whereas black is a little bit
stuck because everywhere you mentioned
is a huge drawback and that it loosens
the protection to e4 Knight whereas
white can just kind of freely expand for
the time being right and you know an
idea with I wouldn't play it but b4 to
b5 at some point is an option because I
wouldn't do it because the c3 pawn now
becomes weak right portent Lee if you
can go b4 b5 maybe your knight can jump
into e5 really quickly and there's
another idea of rook so you want to go
to pawn c4 and again loosen that defense
of the knight on e4 well it'll be
interesting to see if cariocans sticks
with this approach of the London and we
already talked about the fact that he
played it super successfully against
Nepal Miyoshi
in the quarterfinals to win that match
and actually dominate that match and get
here to play Nakamura so I'm expecting
this might be a structure that we become
very familiar with before the day is
done yeah absolutely I mean like you
said if it ain't broke don't fix it
right so right he crushed me Poe that
wasn't even a match at a certain point
that was just a demolition so yeah you
know I think it's it's shown him good
results and he's slightly better in this
position as New York city traffic New
York city traffic reminds Robert of
where he lives and there you go yeah
that's you know the honkin just doesn't
cease but importantly about the
supposition now look at the pawn
structure right look at black spawns all
in the 6th rank or a black zone 3rd rank
yeah they're all loose so at some point
you have to be very careful about some
sort of double attack for you know I was
you know already considered maybe Queen
e3 here yeah or I was gonna suggest an
idea like 95 is even possible now
because after captures first of all
black can't take twice anyway because
there may be ideas of f3 but even if
there isn't a move like Queen III hits
both b6 and h6 and this idea you
highlighted about the week
Hans could be something that we watch
for here is the position opens up
although you're speaking of position
opening up watch out from black at some
point it considered g5 I mean definitely
out of the question I would be hesitant
because c4 from white is coming in short
order and you know now you can't go c4
because night before hits the roof
entity too and the Queen on d3 with a
nice fork but definitely be on the
lookout for an eventual yeah if there
were back to c1 going to c4 here's the
car was going for g5 but the risk of
this type of approach is white has
really been sort of shuffling for the
last several moves putting pieces on
squares that pretend to threaten
something but even if they don't you're
sort of waiting for the position and to
open up and so Hikaru is is putting all
his chips on the idea that if y captures
maybe he used the h5 for an attack
because if he doesn't get something
long-term you just have to think that
black is gonna have some positional
problems in the endgame here right but
if black goes g4 for example then white
can never go f3 you kind of cement that
pawn structure and then black he gets
into going f5f for himself and that way
white has no kind of g4 and it will have
to anticipate a capture in that position
this is a huge concession because by
playing g4 now that if that might
reroute to self to f4 yeah it's not fun
for black and a queen you want exactly
great I was just gonna say that yeah oh
so you've cemented f3 from no longer
being an idea but here comes the Knight
to f4 which will hit East 6 and then an
even outside chances maybe some point
the H v square is used but something
about the tempo of this game I'm just
making an early prediction here I feel
like this is right up cariocans alley
right he's known as the Minister of
Defense but he's also the minister of of
hey I'm gonna be super solid and and
kind of let you let you hurt yourself if
possible so if this position stays on
this track and it eventually opens up I
just I just look at all these pawns
sitting on the same color square as his
light square bishop and feel like White
has the better chances long-term here
yeah I was gonna say before I thought
maybe black could have considered a
sacrifice with Knight takes g3 and just
trying to scoop up three pawns on the
Kings side I you know I don't think it
would have fully provide full
compensation but it definitely was an
idea now it's already too late to do
that just because White has coordinated
his pieces and yeah
in great fashion yeah I mean he's not
comfortable for blacks and we talked
about the fact that in blitz will be
where Sergey Karjakin needs to make his
move
the pre-match predictions this is an
algorithm that we've worked on everybody
just to to evaluate the players and and
all the all the things that they do
online has has these players in a
situation where the the kurakin is
favored in in the blitz even if it's
just by a single game that that's really
where we see Karl can do his best and I
think that if if he if he jumps out to a
lead which the time is also telling here
how often do you see Nakamura down on
time against anybody right it rarely
happened against Fabio no Caruana and I
think that this is this is gonna be an
interesting sign of things to come if
Karl can can score first year right I
think that correcting a great
opportunity instead of going Knight up
for there I thought he was shook on c4
just blasted open the C file open up
that bishop on g2 on that long diagonal
c4 would have really hurt Nakamura in
that last position so he could still do
it but he I think that was the prime
time with the rook on b5 under attack
and this 66 check I don't like what you
know you got to kind of like it but
because a black King is so open well
it's something I mean no I'm already
correcting myself after Queen e6 d5 you
take the knight on c6 and then your
queen goes in d4 with check and a5 is
hanging no white is it yeah this looks
like the opening of the position that we
feared for black if you're in Nakamura
scamp because every pawn you push on the
Kings side looks good as long as there's
pieces on the board everybody but it's
an instructive point no matter what
because eventually it's much harder for
positions to stay close than it is for
them to open up and you always have to
be aware of where your king is gonna
stand should the smoke clear versus
where your opponent's king can stand you
can already see that cardiac and has the
much better much better go of it here
yeah so I would go rook a 7 check if
that's an option I don't know if it's
maybe I'm just hanging if the King moves
and I'm just losing my rook somehow well
the idea everybody there Roberts
pointing out that the black rook takes
white can take and white continues the
assault on the King but maybe just
simple Queen moves right Queen b3 Queen
e2 yep
all those moves also seem to be fine for
white who is who's up a pawn but even if
that a pawn
Falls again the main thing is that this
black King is gonna have issues for the
rest of the game here yeah that King is
not going to find safety and you know
white does have to be careful if the
Queen moves away from E to and allows
pawn to e3 that could be a bit dangerous
for white but in the time being with
this Queen on e2 is very well placed but
now troop d3 right you cut off the
protection of the a6 pawn and actually
how yeah we're d3 how do you like they
say that's a key move right there not
only because it blocks the Queen from
guarding a6 everybody but as long as
that D file is owned by Hikaru it's
gonna be much harder for his King to
ever really come under fire so that's a
key move but the B file is one of those
files that remains open I guess rook b1
would have been met by Queen takes a 6
which would have guarded rook b7 so
Corey Hawkins gonna do his best to
create threats maybe c4 check now
no okay swing the rook to the a file
followed by Brooke a7 but can't black go
Queen e6 now because I don't I mean I
get unless White's on a court name with
rook a 7 check rook d7 very quickly at
some point again black is threatening
III which is very vicious move so
although actually yeah I think c4 check
there was a little more principal check
opened up the Queen and maybe then bring
the rook in everybody but okay Kuryakin
has some idea here with Queen ba looks
the reason I was concerned like if a
king goes to g6 right I guess the Queen
gh you have this is very hard to defend
for black if it is in DB woods and after
rook d7 we see a huge huge switch in the
evaluation after with rook e8 coming in
suddenly black is is not in time to get
moves like rook e1 or e3 check you would
love if the pawn was already on e3 here
everybody just for the record rook d1
checked would be followed by Brooke h1
mate and so Hikaru throws in e3 as a
desperate attempt the cardiac end might
indeed blunder that idea but I think
we're about to see the Russian get on
the board first here well it's yeah
simple win now Queen h8 check exactly I
was just playing your king g6 rook GA
check KH v e5 in a second and if by up 7
the same the same idea is happening here
the Queen and Brooke are rolling rolling
toward the king side we see her Caro
kinda kind of scowling they're kind of
trying to calculate the end of the game
like that Queen g7 Czech can you say
brookey a check you know King D 5 and
then Queenie Queen D for checkmate
excuse me
yep so it's a force mate but yeah it's
just unfortunate for her car that he's
just barely not in time to get the
counter-attack but a nice victory for
you know yep there it is
well the final position would have seen
Queenie five everybody for checkmate but
okay so Hikaru doesn't even make cardiac
can play it on the board but just to
show you on the analysis board here
Queenie five would have done the trick
so all right well there you go a Game
one is in the books the start has been
fast and furious Robert what we have
here is this is exactly what people have
talked about as far as this match goes
Sergey Karjakin is the reigning world
blitz champion for those of you who
spend most of your time watching online
chess certainly hit car Nakamura is
gonna be a more well known commodity but
this is this is it I mean this is why
the our own predictions the stats and
algorithms we prepared a lot of people
look at this match as yes Nakamura is
the huge favorite and bullet but Robert
that's a that's a big win what does
Nakamura need to do to show that he's
not gonna get run over in blitz like
Nepal Miyoshi was by the Russian I think
he just has to avoid going on tilt in
situations where you lose a game in the
first one with the black pieces then
sometimes you get the psychological
problem where you think I need to win
the next game and that's not at all in a
car is very experienced he's been part
of many of these speed chess
championship battles I you know he knows
what it takes to win but you can't get
in the mindset where I need it even the
sport no no you need to play the best
moves possible and eventually if you do
that I mean hit cars an amazing player
he'll get his games so I like his choice
in this game I think you know right now
he hasn't really gotten much out of the
position but he has these little threats
I might come to f5 is annoying to deal
with because there are some threats on
the kingside Queen f3 it's very simple
position to play for white so although
he played b3 on the first move which is
a bit obscure but kind of been to
Chicago and uh nonetheless right exactly
I actually I played all the time on
online speed chess but the the points
the holds that in a position like this
you know if black you know allows Knight
come to f5 maybe black and go g6 they're
clear weaknesses by opening up the king
queen e7 came to allow white to go
forward the plan right Knight a5 Queen
f3
options 95 and Queen for your both
screaming to be played here it comes we
look at this position as the Queen and
Knight already with some dangerous
threats you look at g7 you look at age
six you look at the Queen and rook
double on the F file so this is gonna be
and it's already a different kind of
start look at the difference in terms of
time Robert in terms of how Nakamura now
up a minute on time rather than down a
minute so maybe he's maybe he shook off
the nerves a little bit losing that game
- Sergei everyone said Kerry Aachen will
be favored in blitz and maybe he'll
bounce back right here yeah and the
thing is we noticed the time advantage
which is now under a minute but it was
at a like a full minute it's not as
important in the five-minute portion
when there aren't that many pieces on
the board when you still have a lot of
remaining time but that will come in
very handy in the bullet portion that's
what all now come more fans are
expecting get to the bullet crusher and
you know as noted in the five minute
time which'll cardiac and we'll be okay
he'll fight he'll hold his own he's you
know playing quickly enough where it's
not that big of a disadvantage to be
down 45 seconds on the clock but as the
time controls shortens that's when
Nakamura is advantage really increases
right all right so let's talk about this
game here an interesting dynamic of not
not a lot of minor pieces left on the
board Black has the weak C pawn white
has the we keep on your thoughts on on
who's who's got the upper hand here well
as I say black come has to go rook e8
there because rook c8 still runs in the
night takes d5 rook takes d5 pawn d4
forking the Queen and rook on the c5
square so right now for white you know
if you're King h1 already black can't
take on e3 because Knight of 6 is
hanging any VIP like King H 1 I guess
now black can consider making a move
pawn to c4 or may rook after your rook
b8 was probably better and now that I
think about it because rip b8 if Knight
takes e5 you trade rooks on b1 and then
take on e3 because you get rid of the
attack in the F file but now I'm liking
White's position just because the queen
is tied down the knight on f6 which is
really frustrating to deal with so
Knight d4 here already takes control of
the B file again III is not under attack
because the Knight of 6 is in trouble
so you know I guess D takes e4 first is
fine but the point so now from 94
there's no Ruby 8 if route b8 rook takes
B
you have to take with the rook and the
knight c6 four counts so actually I
think the black may already be lost
practically speaking yeah a lot of
pressure here and suddenly you see with
the B file opening up you know why hit
car took on c4 I think he likes this
move rook b5 coming threatening the
Queen on e5 which was not really an
option with the pawn on d5 so taking c4
seems to make more sense now the Takara
did that and I'm looking at dual threats
of rook b5 and knight c6 and like you
said this is looking trickier and
trickier for black to defend but he is
the minister of defense so time to earn
your name if you're certain Hawking well
Dan is also one of those position that
thing's an important lesson that maybe
blacks should not have taken back on c4
material equality shouldn't look a to c8
and just try to say you know what I mean
I don't know if okay see it works but
something like that the point being that
maybe I'll give up upon the inverse of
compensation because look how passive
black is all your blacks are stuck the
Queen on e5 is the only and I put this
in quotes active piece because really
it's just defending the knight on f6 and
controlling yeah so it
and here's rook b5 I mean rook b5 and
even rook b6 looks good Bruce e6 is the
knight right from p6 c b6 really game
over
Oh exam just can't defend the knight
yeah dr. Brooks there's your ideas
perfect Danny yeah the I guess that move
wasn't possible before everybody because
the pawn was previously on a7 guarding
b6 so a5 indeed was a blunder I didn't
realize that but rook b6 comes it has
been played by Hikaru and and we're
gonna have an even score heading into
Game three and the fans are getting
their money's worth this is the kind of
match that that I'm expecting a very
back and forth affair we'll see how how
what happens in bullet but that's two
hours away from now so we're not gonna
worry about that too much but some
decisive chess being played expecting
her car to just gobble up that one on f7
and go for matin actually not game over
rook b7 Knight g5 hitting the Queen on
f7 and protecting h7 and black could
quickly see some compensation here yes
white of course is better you know you
even just retreat your queen though it's
at F - I feel like what has to be doing
well but it's actually not as clear-cut
as I thought a second ago because this
Knight g5 move really saves the day and
I think yeah he to it honestly I don't
think this was premeditated he blundered
rook b6 yeah
fortune knight such a good defender it
shows right the knight protects h7
attacks the piece on f7 yep yeah and
yeah I think black I mean of course is
worse but you're 85 though again that
idea just seems on the table is as well
as when I see six nights right it's just
overnight c6 if black takes at Queen of
fate as well
checkmate everybody so okay so rookie 7
again will I agree with what you said I
think car yakin while he sort of
stumbled into this Knight g5 idea really
just kind of got lucky not really a true
showing of the Minister of Defense here
he had but really to be fair this looks
like it's been really a lot of trouble
for black for a while and Accardo
bobbing his head likely listening to
offspring given his previous
recommendations of weird music he
chooses to listen to him but okay I
think I think re Aachen throws in the
towel here and and Nakamura has even the
score and I will say Danny this was a
perfect game by Nakamura not because
every single him move he made will match
up with alpha zeros recommendation
that's not what I'm saying
right but he went this game without
freaking out without saying I need to
win you know I need to win right he said
I'm just going to make these moves make
the position interesting and complicated
and I'm just gonna outplay my opponent
so a very good strategy by knocking more
in this game and now Queen f3 just kind
of wins on the spot almost any Queen
move and just not not take the bait
right Queen h4 Queen f3 Queen d2 I think
all of them still kept options of coming
and entering in case black gobbles up
the knight on c6 so any one of those
moves Accardo chooses his favorite is
Queen f3 and with that we have an even
match the next game has begun and and
we're back into the London they did not
get enough of London the one in chess
classic yeah they were in London hey
Cara Nakamura is actually still in
London for fans who love knowing where
he's racking up his frequent flier miles
hey Cara chose to stay in London for a
few days recently celebrated a birthday
so he's uh he likes London he's told
he's told me and he's he's actually
still gonna be in London for a few more
days after this we all recognize a hotel
wall when we see it and that's a hotel
room wall there behind her car
yeah yeah he's playing from a hotel but
you know he's hoping that he can reel
this one this match in and I think it's
very important to both these players you
know III don't think that anyone should
take for granted yes it's an online
event and maybe it's not the London
chess classic in terms of you know
that's classical with all the top
players but they take it so seriously as
we talked where the match I thought you
weren't about to do a reference of he
may be in a hotel but he still has
home-field advantage on chess calm but
he dropped the ball which is true he
does play chess calm more than any any
super grandmaster
but yeah so I agree I mean the players
do take this seriously the London is
something that cardiac in has become as
we've said a bit of a specialist and now
officially with the bishop coming to d3
though Robert we're not gonna get the
same line we had last time where we
transpose into that sort of slow
positional grind this is much more of a
traditional London setup you got the two
nights you got the bishop on the Kings
side supporting e5 you've now got this
Bishop on d3 hitting aged seven just in
case black decides to take on g3 he'll
take back with the H pawn so this is
much more of a typical London attacking
setup for white right yeah and it's a
better defense by block as well because
I think this f5 idea was he's giving
white too many free squares right too
much control over the board here look at
the position white has a nice setup very
comfortable no weaknesses whatsoever to
speak of the same time nothing just
black and you know now okay Bishop takes
e4 doesn't actually win upon because the
B to pawn falls at the end after Bishop
before D takes you for Queen for p2 by
the point at large is that black is
actually very solid here and unlike in
the other game White had a very clear
plan oh okay I don't know I was just
about to say that's a that's a unique
decision isn't h7 falling with check
here yeah I guess he's sacrificing I
don't know if he did this on purpose eg
507 500 or a v e5 just got a 4 next but
after E 5 maybe there's queen g6 to h5
no the Queen g6 Queen f7 saves the day
but Carla's is looking around wondering
what he calculated here in g5 yep there
it is Wow this is quite the sacrifice by
a karo if it works out he's given up the
kingside pawn but now the H files opens
a King g7 rook a shape and the promise
is too much of a long
way to get the other yeah and beyond the
age file so I think he blundered I have
a hard time imagining he did this on
purpose it is very interesting I mean I
actually think that yeah I mean it's
still dynamic I agree black has the
bishop pair and was c5 and still the
long term idea of coming to the h5 black
is not out of it but this is a strange
way to stack up on with check for sure
yeah now actually why he's just going to
try with g3 King g2 but now he 5 has to
be considered blasting open the center
and also hitting the g4 pawn I don't
know Danny I think II five now I mean
just why I have to go Bishop f5 there it
looks looks suspicious I think black
could go ahead and sacrifice some more
pawns on the Kings side the g5 pawns on
importance of your by b5 just open it up
let the bishop here do their thing start
attacking on the Kings side and with E
for coming this is this is gonna be
quite the weird gambit if it works out
for her car taking before
that's a strange decision yeah I guess
he wants to I don't like that move what
was the point of that you've improved
the Knights positioning and now after I
visit even possible because the knight
would just pop into f5 exactly as a you
know a nice defensive setup and now ok
black is still dynamically in this game
but it allowed white more activity and I
just think there's a wrong decision here
for example here you can already
consider moves like putting a rook on e
one at some point you want to consider
pawn g3 and then putting your knight on
f5 I guess g3 runs in the e5 yeah right
away it does but g3 King g2 and swinging
white's rook to h1 shouldn't be
shouldn't be forgotten ok you can't play
g3 now everybody that would fall for
Queen takes g3 just a real quick tactic
make sure you never miss the pin on the
diagonal but but I agree I mean what
about whatever idea like rook e1 rook
III at some point if he can dislodge
that Bishop from from b6 and then swing
over to h3 yeah what was this Knight b3
I mean you got to keep this Bishop out
of the game because white is not able to
go g3 as we've discussed with that
Bishop um b6 in Queens h g3 coming so 93
a4 I mean can't black just go a 5 I mean
is that I guess that's good in a sense
right in the strategic sense yeah fixes
on structure on the Queen's move King g7
Robert he says I don't even care if you
trap my bishop
because I threatened checkmate on h2
before you have time to get out oh wow
what a creative defensive move Bishop g6
prepares to meet Rick h8 with the move
Bishop h5 not every day you see a bishop
block of rook on an open file in that
threatens Queen g6 check which is very
powerful so you'll be this I guess rook
if you're a rookie you have to go
Bishop h5 he goes a5 now what's he
saying bishop h5 is gonna be met by f5
oh and he does it I was just wondering
if he could risk fully opening his king
like that and he says he can white
should try to go Queen d2 maybe just
trying to hit the g5 pawn the knight
back on or it's getting really
interesting here I mean because is
blacks not surrender you go F takes G 4
so that's not a threat from the time
being yes at some point cousin Queen to
g6 check right yeah exactly I should I
should have made it more clear by the
exactly we're 6 comes protecting the g6
square yeah please some something about
the coordination here tells you black
just feels a little bit better right I
mean if Queen d2 maybe now you can even
just meet it with f4 you're no longer
afraid of the of the diagonal being open
because your rook is in a nice defensive
spot and maybe you just mobilize with E
5 and e4 and the pawns get going this is
becoming one of those positions where
you start to feel like Black has all the
dynamic potential with the bishops and
in the files that are opening up here
comes Rick h8 by the way Robert Wow
Bishop a6 sacrificing another pawn but
getting the rook on f1 I mean material I
think we're gage 8 is coming though yeah
you're right
oh no what is that why did he take this
surprise he took on f1 d I think I think
I think the tension was favoring black
more than the material if Rick h8 was
played I still wonder how I would have
dealt with that bishop given the main
threat on h2 so interesting well we're
gonna be for actually a move because if
you got Bishop takes d4 C tasty for now
why a black always to be concerned with
Queen c7 check out the rook get some fun
go to e7 with check I mean who's King is
less safe that looks som like blacks
King is less safe so yeah I've staked by
Hikaru make Queen h2 is possible here
but I don't know why I didn't play it in
the first place and he's gonna do it I
agree and then the and the time is
slowly dwindling now for her Caro this
has been a very I mean the truth is
they're very close to even on the clock
but something about her carros time
managed
now after 94 tells me that he he agrees
with you and 94 was a strong move by
Kuryakin right so if you take on before
CD 4 then go Brooke takes f5 something
words that me but rookie 7 check I mean
yeah Kevin is not a happy piece and that
being same story we saw from Game one
good yeah
nobody I mean that's said that if
they're Bishop d4 CD four rook f5 I mean
it's not like Leone rook F FA first but
something white King is too happy but
now rookie 7 check for what Bishop g6
looks like you know like someone kind of
unleashing an attack on the black yeah
well there's a there's an immediate may
threat on h7 but black really risk them
with like chief or King G oh no that
wouldn't stop made everybody rock a7 and
rook h5 would be a fun way for this one
to end so so yeah Bishop rook e7 and
Bishop g6 seems pretty straightforward
for the back rank but that's not fun
right rookie 7 checks something like
King g8 or h8 I guess does prevent it an
interesting decision there car dock and
taking what's his thought about why I
guess the Brooks coming off the board he
thinks it's even harder for this king to
have defenders even feels even more
naked with one more set of pieces gone
but I actually I actually think White's
attacking chances were better with the
other heavy piece so this is that's it
that's a strange decision by cardiac and
maybe he Caro can weasel his way out
because if everything simplifies here
Robert we know the Queen and rook are
much better than the Queen and Bishop in
the endgame right so this is something
that if Hikaru can coordinate
maybe Corey Aachen regrets that trade on
f6 although I think it cars in big
trouble if to remove like Queen to d2
hitting with a 5 and g5 yeah you just
play Queen e2 it's not fun from black
tip with the weak King down how many
pawns is white up one two three four so
you know white has three pawns for the
exchange right now and it's about to
gobble up another one if the note that
Queen takes a5 rook c2 is not possible
because of f6 renegade pawn check
picking up the Brooke on c2 so maybe
wouldn't lead to a mate because Queenie
4 check after that right so Bishop h5
played to play Bishop of 3 on Queenie 4
check yeah this has to be great for
white you have three pawns for an
exchange blacks king is not happy
bishop will come to f3 at some point
which will defend the kingside I mean
here mmm I guess queen of snakes is a
good move tonight running Brooke c4 and
Queen takes a five to say time the
bishop g6 back maybe but then rook c4 I
mean I guess you know black can't really
just go for all the pawns go to bishop
g6 rook c4 Queen takes a5 the black king
is in very big danger there so you have
to be careful as black not to just get
too greedy but the same time Bishop d6
Queen e7 back you have a repetition of
position so I'm not sure if white is
really making for any progress there so
I yeah I mean but it's it's a strange
position where white is also constantly
afraid of getting over aggressive with
his Queen and black sort of flipping the
script bringing the rook down in the
Queen entering quickly something about
the time scramble here makes me start to
favor her Carl from a practical
perspective that that we know how Hikaru
handles himself in these situations of
the bullet the bullet situation so what
does cardiac and assessing here why
hasn't he just played Bishop g6 okay
what's the bishop now the advantage here
for a car everybody is without the
bishop on g6 suddenly you can be more
aggressive as black because when this
Queen eventually comes into c7 the black
King is no longer just being mated as it
was before with the bishop on g6
yeah that's an essential point here and
now already you know if Queen takes a
five am i just running the Queen takes
d4 because both a7 and c7 would be
covered yeah it feels like White's
practical pressure is slipping and
suddenly if black is gobbling a4 and d4
to me the the evaluation has changed
here you have to you have to start
liking Blacks chances for the rook to
eventually I'll play the bishop and if
the Queen's get traded that that's
definitely tells the tale is if the
Queen's are off the board the pawns on
b2 and d4 on dark squares and cannot be
guarded so I think for the time being
white is doing just fine the queen is
stuck on f6 protecting g5 a karo offered
a draw actually and just decided he
didn't think it was worth note note
everybody that part of the big reason
for that was just that you have a
position where black was black is afraid
to take d4 because of 85 hanging can't
take deep for with the Queen because g5
hangs so the carter's didn't feel that
there was enough to play for
well man I don't know if we've had this
exciting of a half an hour to start a
match in a while this is this has truly
been back and forth with the last few
matches Carlsen beating so grish ik
karak and beating nepo I feel like the
last few matches the favorite
established themselves early and this
one has been anything but yet I feel
like the gameplay has been quite steady
and the fact that neither side has made
any egregious blunders at this point you
know each side milked out a win in the
first two games but that game was a kind
of a back and forth battle where Hikaru
looked very interesting with his early
g.push and you open h-file then at some
point Sergey was better so it's been a
back and forth battle and you said it's
been fascinating to see unfold and
already we see it's kind of a weird
opening again because Park you starting
with pawn b3 I was just gonna ask you
about that so it car was now played be
free twice you said this is a obviously
a weapon you played he plays a lot in
blitz it's a unique position at least
from standard theory is that is that
gonna be the continued approach here I
think from a practical perspective we're
seeing the same thing we saw last time
the car was white
he's already established a massive time
advantage he's over 5 minutes right now
he's got more time than he started with
that's a big edge in playing a system
like this that you know well with b3
right
yeah that's the whole point is ok
if c5 now doesn't that just pick up
stuff Oh wasting Bishop c5 made Queen
takes e5 yeah that's bad good it should
c5 will take c5 Bishop f7 rook f7 Queen
takes Queen so it looks like White's up
a queen but then Knight d7 picks up the
rook on a1 so that would have been a
sham for for white you don't have sound
pretty funny yeah to blunder yourself
into a queen sacrifice yep but you know
the point at large is that I think that
as maybe in bullet you'll see a car play
a little bit more main lines it also
depends on the match score right now
it's even they're kind of feeling each
other out of it right car yakun he's a
very well-prepared player right so by
taking him out of his theory look at it
as you as you keep pointing out and very
doing a good job of pointing of doing so
essentially that look at the clock right
gaining a 30-second advantage within the
first 15 moves the game is quite a nice
edge yes and if again and you know
already look at White's position right
you have this pin knight on f6 the
bishop
seven why can consider a pawn minority
attack here
it's like black is doing so poorly
either but the point is that you know he
has his ideas he's got his strategies in
mind he's not trying to get anything too
crazy for the time being and so I think
it's a decent set up by Hikaru and he's
in the opt-in you do it until he just
really isn't getting in yeah the last
game was simple two minor pieces came
off you had the Knights with different
pawn weaknesses a car eventually
generated that initiative on the F file
this is not gonna lead to an attacking
game on the F file but you already
highlighted the positional plan of
minority attack I'll show everybody what
that is whenever you have two pawns
versus three pawns by definition that
means you have the one you are the one
with the open file so I carry on already
playing that long-term defensive idea
you're sort of over protecting this b5
square because you're preventing white
from starting a pawn storm where moves
like b5 might really create entryway so
that's a instructive take away that
Robert has mentioned very quickly we
forgot to have my jingle Bobby has
teaching moments but will love will give
you credit for the teaching moment
anyway yeah and the thing is look at
this the board right now right Black has
a three on two on the A to C files and
white has a four on three on the E to H
files yep the important point is in an
endgame that's when I actually might
become easier for black to start pushing
those pawns yeah for the time being
they're very stuck because if you ever
move your beep on then your c6 pawn
becomes very weak and from White's
perspective at some point you want to
consider the movie for as but it does
you know it attacks the rook for one
move but at the same time then what and
the e4 pawn can become a target and said
he puts just a for a second I thought we
had a straight-up blunder was it was
Rick t7 yeah yep yeah that's Corey
Aachen kinda blows blows out air there
something something was missed when when
the Russian moved his rook off the back
rank everybody the rook needed to stay
over here tonight on our force coming
next and there goes the game yeah hikaru
sort of acknowledging that that he also
believes he's winning with the head Bob
which it was number 7 but which is
different than Hikaru's look number 7 it
was head Bob number 7 similar to love
potion number 9 but okay we've got we've
got a
now wait a second the Minister of
Defense has made me swindled himself
through no take c5 Queen takes b6 pawn
East six house yeah Queen takes b6 here
comes e6 it's just gonna be crushing for
white and Hikaru knows it he pushes it
instantly the one minute time advantage
combined with the the massive attack you
know if it were not for this East six
move black would have been getting out
of it but of course these six came in a
timely manner now many options queen f2
Knight takes c6 fine there's Knight 66
he's lead of two would be a sassy little
little finish they're sort of surprising
black that the the obvious rook takes c6
recapture or even Knight takes c6
cleanup - it seems like a nice way to
expose the ephod didn't I just say that
we wouldn't have a crushing attack on
the F file in this game Robert you did
say an I said there weren't any blunder
so I think we both do that we that's a
clippable moment the fans love every
time I'm wrong which happens often all
right so just rook takes f7 and then
Queen f2 or Knight f4 followed by Queen
c4 check our lights out Wow well that's
that that how did that how did that
switch so quickly to a crushing attack I
guess it all just happened as we backup
on the analysis board with the when when
cardiac and blundered rook d7 had to
play rook c8 so so right now if we're
evaluating blunders and with Hikaru
expected to win this game and jump into
a one-game lead the the Russian hasn't
had his a-game going so far
nope and it's a you know it's funny
obviously Sergei is an amazing player
but something about chess principles
right he kept his rooks on the dump on
the open files doubled on the open file
yup they forgot back rank you remember
one chest principle and you're
forgetting about the other right and
you're protecting each other give me
your queen enough space to breathe and
unfortunately for him it was not in a
timely fashion and of course he's now
just completely lost so whoa what tries
to find a little swindle with the move
b5 Intermezzo but I mean yeah you know
most moves just seem to work here it was
a nice little idea prevented him from
losing the full rook on the spot he's
still only down the exchange but okay
it's an exchange with with a pretty easy
win so this is pretty common for players
even though they would resign this game
and an over the board tournament
everybody black isn't gonna resign here
one because it splits two because
match like this where you're gonna play
2930 games you have to work out your
nerves a little bit sometimes you make
moves and play out the endgame just to
make sure that you continue to settle in
we're about 45 minutes into the match
now Robert with 51 minutes remaining
here in the 5-2 portion so I expect
cardiac into play this one out for a
little while longer yeah and I mean I
think we don't quite know exactly how
strong Sergei is in the bullet portion
because he's only been playing a couple
of matches on chess calm he seems very
very good we heard Sasha Gray shook say
don't count Sergei out anyway I think
even for him but actually this position
is not as easy as a car would like
because at some point black will try to
push the C pawn or an even right now c4
and try to get some kind of counter play
of course the black king is not very
safe so at some point Queen a5 will be
pretty annoying to deal with as well but
you have to play a position like this on
because there is still hope yeah and
again and even if he even if he doesn't
doesn't find a way to win and come back
it's it's still something that I think
helps him settle in although from a
match perspective I guess if Sergei
agreed with all of our evaluation that
his real chance to get elitism blitz
then you could argue that that not
playing to many of these lost blitz
games out it may be a good match
strategy he wants to get more games in
when the time controls longer you can
see everybody we have five minutes and
three minutes and bullet to give himself
a chance to have a lead heading into the
bullet regardless of how cardiac and in
bullet
Robert against nepo and against others I
mean no it nobody is like playing Hikaru
and bullet right and then so I I would
almost argue okay if he holds the draw
I'll certainly be eating my words here
and he looks like he may be on his way
to doing it
hash tag hash tag Minister of Defense
does he have a hash tag yet for the
Minister of Defense I mean seriously I
think he will not hold the draw but he
is getting closer and closer which is
surprising cuz think how easy it looked
at the very beginning of this
yeah well Hikaru is not a car leaning in
there that's Hikaru focused look number
14 head-on Paul he he knows he needs to
focus here
but yeah not so easy but the problem is
at some point white is gonna poke that
night away from me for with the King to
d3 order you probably you have to give
rook b5 check actually come back the
other way try to get the King to go back
to the first rank maybe I sorry back to
the 6th rank and then play rook e5 No so
how is this gonna work actually because
the problem is any time you go King up
three maybe now they came three the C
pawn is very fast I came from Knight d6
and that C pawn is hmm I mean koe I came
for Knight d6 just go rub g8 I think
this has to be what do you you provoke
glad to go c3 and then you bring your
King back to e2 and get the on yeah you
go back please
but if you push it make it before sit up
the board then I think your chances are
good so rook g8 maybe then King before
that way you don't have to move it too
early I mean then Brooke she's 6 well
those are not the those are not the
early numbered Hikaru phases of feigned
focus he's really I think he's really
frustrated with karaoke and defending
this position so far a little irritated
with what with what Sergei has been able
to do and again one of the biggest
strengths of cotton we talked about his
nerves of steel you and I many times a
couple years ago when he when he played
his World Championship matching his
Carlsen a blunder or not he just doesn't
lose his his focus and doesn't doesn't
have an emotional approach to the game
so the fact that he held on when the
position was almost resigned a ball is
already an impressive feat yeah he okay
you know he really does a good job of
making things complicated
even when things seem simple but right
now I think it's about that time
yeah and if c3 can like just sacrifice
the rook for the night get the King in
front and win with the pawns I think so
no I think Rick's b5 should do the trick
here
yeah that's straight forward winning
king upon ending always important
everybody we talked about a lot
instructive moments you have to be able
to transition efficiently not try to win
end games that allow your opponent more
practical chances so don't miss your
chance to transposition and after that
cardiac ins gonna resign I think
King b3 will just be met by g5 and the
pawn runs and yep the towel has been
thrown and we have a lead for the
American in the 5-2 portion so car
Accardo showing that everyone everyone
predicting that Corey Aachen would be
the heavy favorite and blitz was wrong
at this point yeah I think both players
advantages have been overstated I think
in the bullet it'll be close I think in
this portion will be close and three
minute portion will be close
they're about level in these quick time
controls I mean I would have to give the
nod take card just based on the fact
that he is the most experienced chess
calm player ever right and he out
fantastic and it's not taking anything
away from either player to say that
they're you know level I think it's
complement to both there at such a high
level of play that they're worthy
competitors I think at some point you
will see how this gaming goes but Sergei
we might see him actually shift away
from the London if he you know stop stop
skating the position that he wants we
saw in the last time played they hit
karo got a pretty good looking position
so yeah it was interesting right we had
the weird blunder of the h7 pawn or was
it a blunder a kind of thing I would bet
we'll see Sergei stick with the London
of humor games but since we've seen this
opening let's remind everybody real
quick what we've been talking about as
far as their overall match records on
chess calm Robert said it car was the
most experienced you see with an
all-time six in one record this is all
time
Sergei playing in his first ever speech
as championship only a two and OH record
so while we do expect it to be close
yeah this is um this is really gonna be
gonna be big to me I mean you said you
think both advantaged overstated all
kind of disagree and say I do not think
a car was advantage and bullet is
overstated I think that I think that
Sergei has to have some sort of striking
in the score and either five two or
three two I just do not expect a car or
not to win the bullet by it by at least
two or three games if not three or four
so but we'll see resi especially not the
way Surya is playing right now what is
this open like what I don't I don't know
what's happened here but somehow Weis
pieces all retreat it's like their
initial squares it looks like white
hasn't been moving his night back and
forth which is kind of dated by movie to
you know an e5 to d3 but I was black
like several moves
up in development Here I am
you asked me and I was absent bueller
bueller I don't know how black
acceptable moves interval I guess I
sacrifice the positional weakness on d5
so Sergei saying if I do get castled
record Roca you do have this position of
weakness but Accardo is not gonna let
that stand right if white castle's I'm
sure black we'll just punch d4 through
right so very straight I don't know
something very odd happened this game
but back to the earlier point about the
match strategy and whose favorite and
what time betray I definitely agree with
you I think that Hakkar is the favorite
in the bullet but remember there's not
pure bullets got the 1 second increment
it's true right Sergei his chances but
as we've seen thus far
I mean Sergei will really have to bring
his a + + + game into the bullet if he's
gonna stand a chance because he can't be
down a game heading into the most
fearsome bullet player right well maybe
with the exception being magnus carlsen
but you know of course that's if here if
your other competitor at that level as
magnus you're doing something right so
here ok you're not getting anything with
the white pieces maybe actually it's a
nice move though Queen B 3 right as soon
as black played Queen c4 you're thinking
oh why it's not getting the King out of
the center but Sergei plays Queen b3 and
and the endgame will likely still favor
white a little bit because if you traded
here everybody
now the a file opens up if you're trying
to eliminate the isolated pawn weakness
you open up the bishop on g2 so I think
I think Queen b3 was actually a really
nice move to put the question to her car
oh yeah it was I was about to eat my own
words and say well I think black is
totally fine then I'm looking at him
like after Queen b3 it's actually not
easy to make a move right you know make
a move but I'm talking about strategy
right Queen takes b3 is you just said a
takes b3 now the pawn a7 is under attack
and you know the bishop on g2 is very
happy Bishop g4 so interesting movie was
threatening meydani - we all love a
check my threat but after the trade on
c4 is white just gonna gobble b2 know
you'd be 7 no then rook b8 and rook b2
would have been a problem you know you
could have done that Dan you could have
taken on b7 gone rook b8 Bishop a6 rook
be - Bishop takes you forward check and
then castle
kingside but yeah this seems better why
open up the position for your blacks
benefit when you can just sit and now
work a b8 a7 hangs if worked d7 well
then I guess White's gonna just try to
take over the default we go an age three
maybe maybe you could almost even play
f3 but now I guess f3 would be met by
Bishop a5 Bishop d3 so you'd rather keep
your Bishop open with h3 and then try
for rook to d1 we're gonna see if it car
oh well excuse me Sergei can actually go
for that he decides not to so rookie one
the the good thing is the rook a on a
can't move yet cuz a7 is hanging right
looking kind of a weird move I guess
you're at some point what causing on f4
kicking them from be 5 and using the
e-file so it doesn't make sense right
and if you're here like what are you
dude you got a five it'll say a weird
move but one of the things that rook e1
did I guess is it prevented black from
perhaps having ideas of Bishop e2
attempt oh and maybe sinking in this
Bishop on three no it's a very good
point dinner because h3 would have been
met by Bishop e2 in the right moments so
maybe now maybe now Sergei will go back
to h3 and so I like your idea of f4
though at some point that's a shot Black
has to watch out for cuz this Bishop is
not as solid there as it first looks and
don't don't take on eight oh don't take
on heaven because I thought rook d2 here
it gives a good kamma straight he
decides to do it he's gonna call
Hikaru's bluff and he's sick he's six
here's a nice move oh and I'm b5 but
okay he's gonna be five before but Denny
I was just say b6 the bishop has to take
um b6 and then you go rip b8 and take on
b2 right yet you get a ton of counter
play there with b2 falling everybody the
c3 pawn will go next so highlighting
your idea on the analysis board there
partner that was interesting but Hakkar
was getting play anyway with this before
move the biggest thing I'm noticing here
is that he Cara was down on time
uncharacteristically so we'll see if
that plays a factor or maybe just Sergei
is recognizing that he just can't
continue to get under time pressure
against the Americans so he's so he's
playing faster but I like this like way
less than what I mean maybe in part
because I suggested it but the reason I
like b6 Ruby rook takes b2 is you active
counter play with your rooks yep now
you're hitting
counter playing the fact that whites a
little tied down so why is tied to the
pawn on c3 and you know maybe you can
even consider going Bishop at some point
Bishop d4 just moving this a pawn bishop
f1 is a really nice move rook takes you
three rook takes Bishop CV rook see one
you win c4 and now that a pawn is a free
passer so that actually I think Hikaru
he might have eased the tension there a
little too quickly on c3 and gone for
this route d3 strategy maybe I should
have tried something differently Bishop
e2 first I mean I don't know for certain
but I really like that b6 move you just
get the app you know kind of play looks
that you needed instead of a kind of
creating this tension that you hope will
be enough compensation no I highlighted
it a couple times in the analysis board
even though it was your idea I still
agreed with it and I agree and now with
the with the attention being eased as
you've said the oh wow hey Cardos all-in
now thinking he's got to get some kind
of play didn't want to just lose the c4
pawn straight up but something tells me
this is a bit of an recognizing my
positions on tilt sacrifice by Hikaru
yeah and note that king of seven was
necessary because pawn d2 last movement
allowed Bishop takes d2 Bishop takes d2
rook c8 check Bishop takes c8 and rook
b8 pinning the bishop on the back rank
so I said he goes the King was already
out of 7 then d2 would be a nice move
and White's still better but here well
now he is threatening d2 and Sergei has
to find some way to stop this past deep
on the can uf3 maybe and the idea is
that Bishop takes f3
now that rook on see it's no longer
protected so in your I should play
forgive to what tempo maybe yeah f3
be sure to Bishop d2 but then black just
takes hundy 2 and goes Bishop e3 check
and pawn D - yeah and that's very nice
either so that's an interesting shot h3
trying to deflect the bishop from this
very useful diagonal where it guards the
d1 square for the pond
hey Carlos says I'll take it but
something that the issue was sacrificing
the exchange there's you don't there's
gonna be a way for Sergei to give back
the material and gobble this D pawn and
then you know you just the rook is it's
just too strong okay though yeah exactly
Bishop f5 the problem is the rooks are
not coordinated very well
so okay King the King goes to g6 and BT
just plays rook takes d2 now gives back
yeah Tyrael yeah yeah either way you
take on D - you're gonna have to give up
your rook for the bishop so rook Bishop
takes D - maybe bit by Brook to d8 yeah
and then you take on c3 so kind of
similar you're suggesting it yeah either
way maybe not with King F to here and
just maybe game the tempo with your King
moving in should be a draw right so King
F - bishop C to D to create an obstacle
or bishops ensue no that's uh I mean no
creative way created by I agree totally
he's a stealing one from the Minister of
Defense playbook right there
and this exchange sacrifice was very
smart in the end you know actually I
wonder if kinda one of those things
where I wonder if maybe initially Sergei
should not have captured back on d3 like
I'm right what would be one first and
now a leave again leaving the tension
the rook couldn't move from d3 because
the bhishma c3 was still hanging right
so I you know it's a really good
teaching moment there what is yeah I
highlighted that back on the analysis
board that perhaps it was a moment where
pause to think about the sacrifice but
but okay now now Sergei is sort of
trying to get desperate counter play
against the King but the risk is that if
it fails and he ends up losing back the
exchange anyway then wow hey car was
shaking his head he feels like he missed
something not sure exactly what but
karyakin offers a draw and what was what
is that what is going on here as far as
their decision to take that draw I
wondered but too late now
Bishop's opposite God bishops and just
not enough I'm interesting to have the
game end so quickly there but neither
player really thinking that there was
much to play for I think that helps
karak and I think I think I think it
might have been in hi Carla's interest
to play those games out again take more
time off the total game clock everybody
that is a dynamic that makes the SCC the
speech has championship different than
other chess tournaments because
hikaru wants to get to faster time
controls given his strength Sergei wants
to get as many points on the board as he
can before he's put up against the
bullet wall so those things always seem
little like we're adding sort of hype or
exaggerating some point early in the
match Robert but usually by the end
those sort of things come back to haunt
you and we've seen a lot of these
players like Grichuk he's played in a
few of these and and he's now eliminated
by Carlson but you know he's talked
openly about his thoughts about the mass
strategy and that he's tried to tried to
make games last longer in the early time
controls so I wonder if Sergei put any
thought into that about knowing he needs
to get blitz wins maybe that's why he
offered the draw and Hikaru shouldn't
have taken it you know a day I'm gonna
go on a limb and say this we all think
that a car was better than bullet but I
also think that a car does not believe
he's worse at the normal blitz time
controls but why he's afraid to your
make up if it's gonna be a draw in
position on move 15 and just instead of
milking the clock and you know getting
it down to the short of time with trolls
right he's like 1 5 minute I can beat
him in 5 min and he's proving something
to himself which is I think important if
he is to win this match to play Magnus
next so right I think that's the reason
why we don't see the cards they're
wasting all the time and just right I
mean time is left in this section
no absolutely it makes sense I mean in
all these players you know to be that
good you you you want to believe you are
the best and all these time controls but
III agree with you and I think that
Ricardo's overall you know speed chess
championship record six and one in the
format with that single loss coming to
you know everyone you know who right he
who must not be man named Magnus Carlsen
so so a carro is pretty much the best in
the world at all these time controls
unless he's playing Magnus Carlsen so so
okay I agree and I it'll be interesting
to see here now Hikaru gets the white
pieces that's another thing to note that
taking that draw didn't really hurt from
the perspective that he's hidden he's
been holding draws with black and Hikaru
Picaro has not not one with white yet
right Hikaru has won both games with
white we'll see if he can get it make it
a trio right now yeah it started again
from
b3 but we have transitioned into
something it looks like start with one
d4 a very normal position here look at
this move Queen a8 very important look
at the pawn on g2 in the bishop and b7 a
queen on a line up perfectly
and at some point black can't even
consider sacrificing a piece you know
with Bishop takes g2 I wouldn't do that
I mean after already actually think
whites in trouble because real Queen c2
can't black just go Bishop b4 and I saw
a quick intermediate move yeah and he
would have for sure i and now now Luke
takes D to Queen B - Knight b3 right I
think that looks good it's good shot
rump d2 Queen use unite b3 you move the
Queen I take on c1 g2 still hanging at
the end of that yeah it just looks like
something went wrong for a carve out of
the opening here
no okay well Sergei not in bad shape by
just over pressing on the d2 night
because that that's another question is
exactly how are you gonna defend that
piece yeah actually I said ooh but this
might just be a great move I mean I
don't see you exactly what white plans
do Brooksie to you trade everything on
d2 and they 190 a4 at the end so the
minimum you pick up the two bishops
those g2 is still hanging I think that
Brooke takes D to a movie go was just a
nice tactical shot that probably won't I
mean I don't have an engine in front of
me so maybe I'm wrong but I didn't see a
way at least at first glance that white
gets out of that rookie ii was i think
great and now rook CT was the only move
here so i don't know what happens yeah i
was wondering if there was maybe a queen
sac so i always have to go back and
check analysis on the chance as a queen
sac
i don't think there was so with black
thinking of the broken again you know me
queen sax god i gotta check them off the
list but okay rook c2 is now played and
I'm wondering is okay Knight b3 is an
exchange sac with the c7 hanging but I'm
wondering if there would be a crazy
amount of tactics on d2 so that along
with the simple straightforward as you
said trade everything on d2 put the pony
on a for win the bishop here at the very
least which in an open end game is gonna
be a big advantage I wonder if there's
even something else certainly Sergei is
taking his time to make sure there's not
not some other way to bring pressure to
the knight on D - yeah and look at
Sergei his clock he's still ahead he's
been spending some time lately but hey
Carson a lot of time in his rook c2
moves so he kind of allowed Sergei to
get the advantage on the clock I don't
know I mean something was very weird
about Weiss position right there's a pin
on the D file so
okay he ended up capturing here he's
going for it in 94 94 instead of going
for the bishop here on e4 oh I mean
that's the natural square putting a
piece in the center but again despite
despite all the tempo moves Black has
had so to speak right the captures and
the tempo moves on the Queen nothing
concrete to show for it at this point
and now he's simply retreating the
knight back to f6 makes me feel even
more sure that that the Russian missed
his chance earlier with the combination
you highlighted with rook takes t2 ah
yeah I mean this is just not an
advantage for for black necessarily
right I mean this pains my heart
honestly why I mean tell us about your
heartbreak I mean you know you like that
and what's weird to me actually is the
clock management is that sir he didn't
really I feel like he did take enough
time when he decided on going 94 like
they're really tactic yeah maybe he was
concerned about spending too much time
early but now okay this is just a draw
they can shake hands and they are so
yeah and I'm and you're writing I'm
showing that last combination or that
combination one last time on the
analysis board just everyone can
remember your point there and I agree
with you I think I think it was clearly
the clearly the best the best
opportunity for black to get an edge
maybe Sergei calculated knew he missed
it and decided there really was nothing
more to go for but okay I mean he's he's
missed a couple opportunities he's only
down by a game and he's got 30 minutes
to strike back
that's good probably gonna be at least
three more five-minute games and here we
have here we have a boring Berlin but
but we'll see if they can if they can
make something magical happen on the
e-file that surprises us well I figured
that Sergei would change is opening at
some point I was not expecting it to be
this particular opening a little
disappointing considering we've had a
lot of fun thus far in the match in
terms of openings and the positions that
have been achieved but we're gonna need
a little maneuvering battle now nice
coming to take a better breath Robert
the Berlin is still chess okay the
Berlin is still chess you know actually
I think what's better here you know I
really often think the Y is slightly
better
ya know you you have a safe position
that's you know you can kind of expand
and look at blacks
kingside is a little bit exposed there's
no fee and keto so you're gonna bring
her King to g7 at some point but you you
often feel a little bit of a little area
on that side of the board
[Music]
ya know a little more than just a little
area Caro being aggressive with the
Kings side pawns we've seen him do it
all day though right I mean it karo has
has now been afraid to expose his own
Kings position whether it was the black
side of a London and Ord over here the
black side of the Berlin and on that
note
you were right indeed Kuryakin failing
to get what he wanted his last two games
against the London has switched things
up this is the first efore we've seen
from Sergei in the match yeah maybe the
cars on the claim that okay I'll just go
Bishop d7 rook e8 and just you know be
calm and but Knight g7 it's so weird
no but this is this is sort of typical
in a Berlin mayor blacks I think will
play h6 I mean this side this are not in
the Berlin even in a I want to say an
exchange French yeah in this structure
to just have pieces rima new ver they're
all sort of holding squares on the
e-file I don't think that either side
really has much too much to claim for an
advantage that's a great call this is an
exchange French that's exactly the
structure is now right yep so okay you
take on g5 yeah is it's not clear where
white puts the pieces you a knight to c5
black a little b6 which may create
another target but still is just you're
pushing white back and if some point I
see I have to highlight that moment cuz
can somebody please clip that moment
from the Twitter chat so Hikaru Hikaru
has pre moved H takes g5 anticipating
the capture and then darted away to
reassume use the restroom and so he
probably gained about another 15 20
seconds with that pre move on the clock
so if someone could please clip that
moment that is that is pro tip 101 if
you believed that there's a high chance
of a capture always pre move capture cuz
in this position everybody if white had
not taken on g5 then the move age 65
would have just been reset right there
wouldn't have been a prima blunder so
Hikaru just if he ends up coming back
and using that time well and now he's
about he's up about 30 seconds here
Robert I'm gonna call that is the
clippable moment of the day so far and I
gotta give a shout-out to chest pain 94
in the twitch
because she says all caps wash your
hands naka wash your hands nook classic
classic yesterday thanks to yesterday by
the way we haven't been given much love
to all of you chatters out there I want
to say also just saw a comment by Divis
Jess who who disagree with me said that
Berlin is not just Annie it's torture
frowny face so well this is not gonna be
a Berlin here twitch chat and chefs TV
chat thanks to everybody for being here
this is now gonna become a position
where White House to justify a peace
sacrifice so this should this should be
heating up here soon yeah I mean the
peace act for two pawns so that's not
quite enough compensation just purely my
material but if you look at the black
King yep it's actually quite safe there
are a lot of minor pieces there but
they're gonna say they're in weird
positions and all of a sudden g4 and
although by possibly okay he's gonna
take with you five but I was gonna say
followed by a f4 and you know one of
those positions where if you're just
sacrificing a piece for pawns everybody
usually you're in the wrong business cuz
the miners will almost always find time
but if you can do it with Tempe and if
those pawns can quickly become past a
lot of times you can get away with it so
Hikaru knows that he's just gonna give
the minor back and probably be the only
one who could actually win this endgame
because regardless of how he takes on f5
here everybody this a pawn will get
blockaded and black structure on the
Kings side is just much healthier so
there's a nice transitional sacrifice
there by Hikaru oh absolutely and very
strangely Sergei offered a draw and a
card declined it because why would black
ever accept a draw here you're gonna be
up upon in all likelihood when you get
five balls and even if you don't take it
you work around it you put your king on
e6 I'm gonna five perfectly placed you
could move your rook either to g8 or H a
try to create some problems for white
and I mean there's yeah there's clearly
black is just doing very well here yep
absolutely
and now he's up that clear pawn and
we'll be the only one who can win for
the next series of move this is exactly
where you want to be if you talk about
this match from a Karnataka Morris
perspective playing for two results in
the five minute and three minute portion
continuing to push this overall game
clock down we only have 25 minutes left
in five minute before things get even
faster so
with Danny very important to note is
look at the a1 square it's a dark color
this five is on the right square I love
when you teach end games it's my
favorite yeah well I mean it is
essential to this end game right because
black is up a clear pawn right white new
is trade off blacks DC and be pawns for
all three of White's pawn and the bishop
yes give up you could sacrifice a bishop
it means getting rid of all those pawns
because an a pawn and in light square
bishop will never be able to promote
once the King gets to the b2 a one
squares
no and Smith love fan and chat just
highlighted that so kudos to him right
as you were talking about it he said you
know the a pawn
again for those who don't know the
endgame Roberts talking about if you
even have this piece the pawn and white
has nothing left as long as this King
reaches the right color corner that is a
theoretical draw despite being up four
points if you keep track that way so
that's a really important thing the
grandmasters noticed right away is the
future potential I wouldn't be surprised
if if Sergei was already thinking that
way Robert when he kind of let the e5
pawn fall for free right so he does he
knows that this should that the only
thing I'll disagree with some is LA fan
who's a diamond member and thanks for
being active in the chat
he said he's he pointed out what you did
Robert but he said he thinks it's still
enough for black I don't I don't really
think so I think this is probably a draw
with best play despite the extra pawn
because of that exact highlight of the
square being the wrong color well hey
carving everything you can to try to win
King b5 name it came to a four but look
his Bishop d7 check right you know hey
Sergei sees everything that hit car was
trying and okay so now King b5 yep
all right yes yes kiyah JTL I do read
the chat as well people are surprised
that we have the chat being read here
comes the c4 and I guess not as he is
making inroads maybe Smith's loss fan
will prove me wrong I still expect
what's the news Danny a four wins for
white a phoner wait you know we talked
about oh you're a buddy checkmate
everybody Robert yes Robert was
fantasizing for a minute about a to was
the only move there yeah white and
Bishop eight you would get out but
that's how that whole area that would
have been oh nothing like a self made in
the middle of an endgame well if you
your Bishop h3 here right you're still
threatening checkmate and d4 runs in a
bishop
checkmate but you can just move the you
through the bishop right bishop you for
the key everybody is this is a checkmate
but d4 doesn't solve it because the
bishop flips to the backdoor and gives a
new chuckling that was Robert's idea
so Bishop a4 is for us but probably
white should be able to draw with just a
little tickle a little bit tickle maybe
I don't know this is getting a little
more difficult now what if I keep the
bishop on e6 though I mean that mr. e6
looks like the register if I go to e6
you can never move your King really and
I don't think see this bishop getting
back here to help in and in cardiac and
agrees yeah this seems this seems like
White's should be able to find that
setup that just prevents black from
making progress yeah it looks like it
drawing now because if your Bishop b3
ago Bishop g4 back if you know King b3 I
started king c1 you have to go King C
for back to protect d5 so we've got FM's
nm Shyam's and GM's all playing guess
the move if you haven't played guess the
movie I go to chess calm and just make
moves on the board as the players play
and it keeps track and it'll tell you if
you're winning guess the move so we'll
try to give a shout out to the top
guessers after this game here yep so
this looks like a pretty set draw and
where's some rich by the way grishnack
was playing guess the move and Sergei
his last match so somebody called Sasha
we love Sasha yeah well here he's found
the right defense the carros gonna think
a little bit make sure he's not missing
any any other last-minute practical
chances but he shakes his head I think
he's acknowledging that he doesn't see
really anything concretely left no we're
not talking about uncle Sasha
Kyah Kyah t1 in the chat not not that
Sasha uncle Sasha hasn't made an
appearance on chess TV for a while so
alright well this will be an interesting
set up here a carro is a legendary look
out look away number nine right there
from Hikaru it's not the same as look
away number six where he's just trying
to remember opening theory or pretending
he forgot something look away number
nine is he knows the result is in the
books and he's just gonna try a few less
things yeah this is where's the wiki
page on Hikaru Nakamura faces by the way
you have to create it I guess I have to
create if I wanted them don't make
yourself on a to not pumpkin King SATA
shout out to Neal Oak who just
subscribed to chess right there let's
get some subs Thank You Neal Oh Neal Oh
ch thank you for all the support all the
subscriptions all of you subscribers in
the chat right now there are many of you
Robert already shoutout to chess Bay who
seems to be like the the chest
subscriber guardian angel in every chess
chatroom as soon as you get going on
your channel Robert I guarantee you
chess pays your first subscriber I just
I'll tell you right now so chess BAE all
the premium members in the chess TV chat
Robert and I had been real focused on
the X's and O's but I do want to give
shout out to all of you and please keep
the comments fun and subscriptions
coming we love those subs thank you so
much for your support yeah this is just
a draw hey Carlos - Carlos loving that
look away number nine right now that's
all we got but it's a draw and it's got
to be in I mean there's nothing again we
see the limitations of the bishops here
not to make it boring for all the fans
the instructional aspects as you see
that the dark squares are just
unchallengeable by either one right of
the diagonal moving pieces and that
creates dynamics and Bishop endings that
don't exist in other endings where a
certain color just can't be challenged
chess BAE there she is again sending the
hearts we love it I thought chess mate
was already a subscriber so uh but it's
probably cuz she subscribed to every
every channel there so thank you chess
BAE and again so the dynamics of the
bishops not being able to challenge
certain colour complexes creates
different certain it creates features
and Bishop endings that as we said just
don't exist in other endings now the
pawn on the light square gives you hope
if you're black if you could somehow
find a way to get your Bishop to target
it but on that note I see zero
opportunities that that Bishop were
targeted one thing you got to give the
card a credit for Robert notice that the
a pawn is no longer a factor he did
create at least the dynamic where if
white blunders black can win because
there's no longer this this safety net
where black and where white is just down
a piece and still draws but but on that
note I think we're still about to see a
draw there's just no way in here that's
pretty funny that black one Bishop age
five to like
hope that white takes for the King on d3
and they go bishop d1 and pick up b3 and
sir gays has such a fortress going on he
just shuffles Bishop you looking for
nothing to do and chest broad just
subscribed the biggest chess channel on
twitch is the chess bras who will there
ever be a chess channel that rivals the
chess bras with their 1200 plus subs and
I'm sure they'll reach 2000 someday I
doubt it but we do love the chess bras
thank you for the sub thank you for Tic
Tac 12 who just subscribed look at that
love the support everybody and let's
let's get an exciting game here hey Caro
and Sergei no more of this shuffle puck
let's get into it let's get into some
more exciting chests in the next 17
minutes all right
faded like Air Jordan said car yakin
looks like Phil Hellmuth our youngin
looks like Phil Hellmuth you know he
looks like Princess Leia look at the
headphones there I mean we already did
this Photoshop contest I won't do it
again but a car Oh a Nadia car oh sorry
Sergei with the headphones if we get a
straight-up shot these two have both
been leaning around a lot you really you
really get that like likeliness of
princess lay in circuit karaoke on the
day of the Star Wars release right
yesterday kitty kitty hiss hiss just
gave out $10 worth of subs on Twitch
thank you so much thank you so much for
that chess chess Alexis thank you for
subscribing look at that hit card Oh
does one last swindle he's gonna play it
out to stalemate I think a cart of did I
agree with you about you know the
perspective you highlighted that I don't
think Accardo thinks he's not better
than card I'll kinda blitz and bullet
but I think a karo did decide that he
was ready to just kind of grind out the
Blitz and maybe move on to the faster
portion yeah Big Foot just subscribed if
you have not followed or subscribed
bigfoots channel and you are a chess
subscriber at either chess or twitch you
should definitely do that Bigfoot is uh
we got hutch watching hutch the the one
and only hutch sorry Robert I know I'm
in subscription shout out mode but hutch
is watching one of the one of the
biggest streamers on Twitch chess or
otherwise hutch is uh hutch is a
celebrity a real celebrity not like not
like Daniel drench who acts like a jerk
and thinks he's a celebrity whoever that
guy has hate that guy but but no anyway
thank you everybody who's subscribing we
really appreciate the love and support
all you premium members in chess TV
we're not forgetting you either all
right Robert chess b3 has been played
we're back to old number one what's
going on here it's deja vu we've seen
this position before we saw a bishop a6
d3 Bishop takes c4 b c4 and d5 in that
other game yep instead it looks like
circuit card I can said I didn't like my
position there I'm gonna change it up
but still I like white here black has
double yeah but was just gonna highlight
that the open F file is really what
gives white the advantage here now Queen
f3 mission GeForce I got to avoid
blundering just pretty simple tactics
but the Knight a5 here still looks good
for white I guess i'ma see I would say
if I was mean
I like the dynamics for white what if I
was trying to take a step back and think
about the position as a whole I think
black is actually doing quite well and
the reason why is that the bishop on c8
is the only bishop on the boards at some
point it can take over that long
diagonal which will for sure be in
blacks favor yep and attack isn't so
great you know okay again but again
we've seen this we've seen this pony
dance literally with the knight it's
moving around and figuratively the the
the knight sort of poking holes at the
Kings side the F file becoming weak and
we saw a car will get his first win as
white and this exact structure so you're
saying you like Lex a shout out to GM
Vacarro mannered monkey and everybody
who just subscribed sorry for all those
who that I missed st toast just wanted
to let everybody know we do see it we
appreciate it but why is this different
than what went in the game that had car
really outplayed Sergei to get his first
win with the white pieces because Sergei
very early on gave up his Bishop for the
night and all those things and do it
again
I was now saying there are some
strategical elements that do favor black
in the fact that you have a LightSquared
bishop and white has no bishop to
counter it that being said the bishop on
a6 now has an absolutely no future
that's none of what we saw before I was
going to say we saw that before and we
saw Sergei because of that lack of
future just give up the bishop so I
agree I agree with you the black
structure of solid I don't think we're
predicting a death a death attack on the
F file as we saw in the karo dude before
but I you know it just feels that white
has cards to poke and prod over
here at the kingside and i and i don't
see a lot of clear plans for why sorry
White has cards to poke and prod I don't
see clear plans for black yeah and now
especially the night coming in d5 it's
gonna be a bit frustrating but at the
same time let's say I ignore it and go
rook a to be 8 ok 195 but I say if you
wouldn't be 895 to go Queen d8 I don't
see a follow-up for white either you're
black well eventually goes c6 kick that
night away from d5 and so I think that
right now black is timely to defend the
position c6 was indeed to stop Knight d5
although not an IV for poking I did I
know you weren't you want to just poke
at things I don't poke and prod you know
what I'm talking about okay a game of
poker love that
alright rook b8 rook b3 and now white is
sort of ant saying and this is a very
instructive trick by the way for the
fans when the rook comes to b3 he's
preparing to double and black doesn't
want to trade because if you trade then
you're sort of helping white structure a
takes and now white has the open a file
to hit a weakness that black doesn't
have to attack himself so that's a
that's a nice little trick to remember
when trying to play a game of chicken
with two rooks tearing each other down
on an open file look for those anchor
spots they call them like where you can
rook lifts see now he Accardo can double
and but these guys are gonna be staring
each other down for some time to come
now
he went from stare stare down to running
back to the F file but you have a great
point there and it's very important for
all viewers to understand that is that
if you instead of just relieving the
tension by taking and exchanging rooks
yeah sometimes you your opponent to take
you and taking on b6 or mb3 helps decide
who's being captured because you take
with the a pawn upon a closed
enter and then you've actually pushed
your D pawn because if the palm is on b3
the policy for then is protected so in
24 is definitely worthwhile push but now
ok so there's been a little bit of
shuffle we're kind of playing hockey
puck yeah shuffle puck is the correct
Mighty Ducks reference but but close no
but I agree with you and I and I think
okay so now that's the what if we're
evaluating weaknesses we have III for
white d6 for black and f5 is a pin
Hikaru is willing to make the trade why
does he like the transit
to this end game with the symmetrical
structure not exactly sure maybe he
feels that night f4 is coming and and
he's gonna get counter play against
black sweet pawns before white but I
like d5 by Sergei he's he's he's
inducing the trade which seems to give
blacks pawns more space and threats than
whites pawns have yeah maybe white
should now move the rook to a3 yep there
it goes I would say Justin now Knight c3
and I kiss running to come in d5 and now
actually if you look back to b3 at some
point you've now the rook isn't
protected on visa look for it look for a
capture on f6 if it wasn't for rookie
one check everybody there could be rook
takes f6 rook takes and Knight takes d5
but rook e1 check would save the day
that's probably why tomorrow plays king
h2 because now rook takes f6 is a little
tactic to keep your eye on although d4
now by black uh-huh there it is but but
c5 is weak on at the same token right
every every action equal and opposite
reaction and now we've got c5 as a
target followed by Knight B to Knight c4
and black is having to worry about both
the c5 and the a6 pawns right but if you
have Ruby 5 here okay I was gonna go
rook b5 but he chooses a row six yeah
now your idea wait okay Knightly for
from black right because the pawn on d3
is pinned so Knight e4 to c3 looks
pretty decent you don't want to go c4
from black too soon because I don't move
I work a 4 will start hitting the D pawn
but what's going on here
I thought 94 was good and moving good
now it looks like May black Trent said
of a mating net with night age 5 to g3
and bring the rook down to e1 I mean
that's obviously wishful thinking but
maybe it's not so wishful of how this
game has continued right now okay so
he's turning Knight f3 now hitting the
rook on e1 and the pawn on h4 so you
know white wait still has some things
going on maybe that pawn to h4 is
overextended right you you push it on
the board trying to create a mating net
but now it's difficult to defend so the
next moment Knight f3 is a rook p7 check
okay he amazing I have three first I
don't think it matters too much yeah but
no you're right that's always the risk
of advancing pawns toward the King to
try to create a mating net as they go
too far from home they'll fall isn't
winning now Ruby I was gonna say but
rook b7 check in 95 is coming in here
exactly you ignore the eight ninety five
ninety five hits the rook the rook is
tied down to guarding the knight on f6
everybody and there's immediate threats
like III can't name all of them fast
enough Knight f7 check Knight g4 check
rook takes f6 and then there's another
subscriber shoutout to metric tensor
who's just subscribed on chess and
everybody that I missed announcing
before we love you thank you so much for
your support
here comes is it gonna be Brooke takes
up 6 or 9 f7 check I think it's gonna be
yeah exactly yeah if so the seven five
pawns falling oh this is so nice of rook
d6 Knight b7 look at that Knight operate
over there never b6 knight c6 that's so
nice rook b6 knight c6 hits the rook and
cuts off this rook from guarding the f6
Knight everybody and Hikaru is about to
strike with white taken a huge aim lead
although what if he goes rook a-15 rook
b1 is there some menos that would be
intense
I think we're k1 here right we're gay
one rook f6 for b1 wow this is getting
crazy rookie there is g4 check but you
just take it I'm Besant with check right
now he's right I can't get out because
if I eventually one of the F ah you
check and skewer me
okay fascinating moment right here
because either Hikaru is going to
calculate himself to a victory or black
has just totally
justified this.h pawn advance which as
we said everybody the whole point try to
create that mating net and then redo a
draw
oh that is it I don't like that why what
was the draw that's exactly the point I
think that white had to go retreat
Knight back to e5 and if you're not
mating black side let me check made then
black is gonna lose but I widen up play
on if it yeah I didn't see a forced draw
honestly I didn't see a force draw
either but the players said there was a
draw apparently the eval said there was
a draw so maybe there was some sort of
professional if you you know you the
point was with the pawn on h4 you do
this g4 check thing like you said yeah
and then like rook g1 rook h1 and like
you can't actually use the other rook to
come down because if you do then he gets
out on the F file yeah yeah okay sorry
for me and Robert going in our heads
there everybody and dealing what a lot
of viewers don't always like about
commentators when they talk about things
you can't follow but hey sorry we're
also chess players and we're trying to
solve the mystery for ourselves at all
times
shoutout to chess coach net who just
subscribed and if you don't follow chess
coach net please go to twitch.tv slash
chess coach net and follow him Frank is
regularly streaming and and doing good
work on Twitch so let's spread the love
to the global chess community please
everybody okay so in with this game we
see it finally a different opening so a
little Italian game did yoga piano and
in general white gets more space or I
see upon a for whereas black is upon a
six yo can consider initiating a pawn
break with d4 at some point you have to
be careful with your knight pin than f3
but at some point I mean now d4 looks
alright as well and again with the extra
space y hopes to avoid any kind of
pressure you know King G tooth pawn h3
at some point might be in the cards
though it for King G to black my just
like Queen d7 so I think black is doing
all right here
another d4 I was gonna say Queen f6 but
maybe the points of you commit your
Queen to f6
maybe then white goes King G chillin h3
so ascetic Argos can h8 with the idea
gone upon at five but now if you're
white you're looking to eat three
protects the knight on f3 so you can
even go Queen b3 here and just get out
of ya the pin on its way
or even Bishop e2 I was about to say I
feel like we saw this structure a few
times when when Fabiano Caruana played
hit car not come or if you missed that
match everybody replay was on November
2nd on Twitch but this structure was
something Hikaru played as black many
times because Fabiano was consistently
playing efore given that we saw this
match start with a London by Sergey we
haven't seen much of the structure but
this sort of tension here on D 45 the
dynamic we're seeing here with the rook
lifts we saw this many times in that
match right and we this may be the last
game we have in the five-minute portion
of this match by the way with only four
and a half minutes left Robert there's a
pretty good chance that this is the last
three minute game for us you mean five
minute games are in yeah any game yes
well I was is last classical type 5 min
game because then we do get the 960 game
which will be very interesting I'm
always like which of these players are
you know fans and strong at the 960 I
think we love Grisha comment sticks it
means like every game he's played yeah I
I think his record in the SEC but Hikaru
and and Magnus Carlsen for those who
don't follow chess news have a match
schedule than chess960 in Norway
sometime I believe in late February
early March N and chess comm we have our
first ever chess960 Championship which
guess who I'm hosting it with Robert who
are you hosting the one and only yasser
sarah Juan is joining me on January 4th
for our first-ever chess960 championship
yes yes himself the yeah the yester so
all right what's going on here black is
just kind of black has to sit tight in
the structure because white has more
space has the pressure on the F file but
what is there a danger of white
overextending when you see B for coming
here this rook being lifted kind of
awkwardly on f3 any thoughts about that
I think I was about to say Bishop f1 h3
at some point will be a bit of a
nuisance
especially if c6 comes in here if the
trade comes with cc-64 and then take on
d5 with the C pawns
Bishop h3 will be annoying just a
take the black off the C file now we see
a transition where look at the pawn
structure
three-on-two on the Queen side for white
c2a files and then five on four from the
D to H files now that pond d6 is a
target it can become an asset if you're
able to push it right now already d5 can
be in the cards right look at what
Sergey is doing he goes Bishop b5 if he
takes an a5 now then black goes d5 and
it's I mean that's definite compensation
for a pawn and it said he okay I'm
surprised by that it cuz now d5 is no
longer on the cards maybe he intends for
the c5 square or the d4 square to
eventually become available for this
night if it can relocate itself to d6
but now my key so f3 filed my rook d3
that was a really bad decision in my
opinion by a car I don't know why King
g2 was playing why just f3 right you
just go f3 go rook d3 and just clamp f3
to Guardi 4 what's your point and then
play rook d3 and as you said clamp and
this night couldn't even go to e8
without being traded by the bishop on e8
so I agree it looks like ooh but there's
a shot c5 then d5 what is good these are
the point everybody the pawn on d6 was
pinned do the rook the Queen couldn't
take as the rook was hanging but d5 may
be exactly what black needs to maintain
the balance so rook d3 here whoa Queen
SEC he just goes all-in I was just
saying rook d3 there and just take over
the D file and said he sacks is queen
and he has Lasker compensation that is
yeah a reminder piece and pawn for a
queen right and good no I like it for
white honestly because you have
sufficient compensation purely
materialistically but as terms of the
position itself okay you have control
over the e-file black is a little bit
cramped yes this Queen can maneuver
wherever it wants to but there are no
clear targets another quick draw and
this is not the last 5 minute game they
squeeze in one more game right before
the time expires which is fascinating
and Wow thinkit's right as we said wow
about the Queen trade the chat you know
diamond member smyth laughs and all the
others every it was like a spamming of
Wow people were fascinated by the Queen
sac but apparently was just a fancy way
to reach an equal engine and yeah and
shout out to everyone's commenting too
fast in the twitch chat who just said
Giri
that was only comedy theory but alright
so now we have the official last game of
the 5 minute portion and we see her car
once again going with B 3 and certainly
opting for very solid setup white can
take over the two bishops by going G 4
and 9 H 4 here but that often leaves the
F 4 square quite vulnerable because
white really wants to play I played it
way white likes like before in those
type of structures and gain space in the
center now e4 will permanently
permanently excuse me leave the F 4
square weak so black you can remove like
90 okay
might be saying well this is a this is
an unbalance a way to get a quickly
unbalanced position this is different
than any of the b3 games we've seen so
far right I mean here you have the
bishop pair and white being all in on
some sort of attacking idea on the Kings
side with f5 coming is he gonna play a
five but the f5 would be met by e5 and
and then the nature of the game changes
again so no y wants to maintain that
tension exactly and another idea that
white potentially had was if black did
not go g5 white could have gone g5
followed up by h4 h5 try to open up the
H violet now you don't wanna do that too
quickly because strategically and
structurally that doesn't actually favor
white for the most part but it is not to
think about Sergei chooses to go for for
trading and put the Bushman of six he's
trying to open up entry ways into the
dark squares here everybody long term I
was wondering if instead of taking a
four of something like Queen to b6
hitting e3 and maintaining the tension
wasn't a better idea for black but I
digress and kitty-kitty his hist
subscribed on Twitch thank you so much
for all your support I like I like
Serge's position here and this b3 game
better than I have in the last two he
got against a car oh yeah you don't
understand c3 by white because he closed
it make our closes between b2 when he
could have went Knight e5 maybe he's
trying to avoid too many potential
trades but 95 looked much more natural
but I guess now the thing is now that
problem of 95 is blacks and take on b3
and if that rook gets down to a 2 it's
gonna be hard to open up that bishop on
the B 2 square so yeah
shoutout to robot just subscribe robot I
think it was robot relay sorry missed
the last part of username thanks for
subscribing on Twitter smyslov fan is
letting us have it diamond member on
chest comm saying everyone complains
about draws but you always want the best
high quality play like in soccer if the
scores 2-1 you had really good technical
high quality play we just need to we
just all need to appreciate accurate
chess and solid defense so no accurate
chess what I don't appreciate is calling
the game to an end before the game has
coming for its natural conclusion so
right I agree with a fan maybe you know
special offense talking to other people
I just think that why not play on in a
position that's actually there's clearly
like no evident draw with two two rooks
and Bishop and pawn against Queen and
rook and all these pawns to left so you
know maybe it's a personal preference I
agree with myself and people you know in
London all chess is dead people are
drawing too much know like those
exciting games all over the place but
back to this particular game now I think
black is taking over Queen 85 here the a
file is an important file it doesn't
look like much at the moment but Queen
at five actually mean d2 or Queen the
before and like many different moves and
the point was after Queen a5 the knight
couldn't take on d7 because b2 is
hanging so yeah it's getting messy here
and the tension on the the the c4 and d5
pawn black never really wants to take on
c4 you open up the bishop on g2 but but
he the black has really held on and made
it made a really strong point on d5
shout out to Vader batter bobcat who
just subscribed on Twitch and I see the
comment from diamond member TX 78109 it
on air thanks for that question I just
that - but cat lion usernames there we
had a kitty kitty we just had a bobcat
like you know I don't know what's going
on today but maybe I'm getting opening
up a can of worms I don't want to get
into it typically that's something I do
on a regular basis
let's analyze let's analyze this
position here because with the rook on a
- I was just gonna say now that the
Queen reorganizing herself to the king
side what are the chances that black
gets a really strong attack here and
Sergei evens the score before we move
into 960 strong attack I don't foresee
but I definitely think that their White
has to be cautious because
especially why does not want to capture
on a two or the point of just a book
they've broken if black captures on e2
then whites happy to close off that
second rank right now white can consider
going Bishop II one where's that Queen
going back to h7 like it's an ugly
square Y so Bishop one is definitely an
option here and after Queen h7 baby then
now going Bishop b4 so just kind of
kicking that Queen away from h4 and then
questioning where's that mmmm d6 going
we can go okay I'm Bishop before first
that last user hallelujah CAD subscribed
just because you mentioned all the kitty
cat names I'm pretty sure but thank you
for the sub no matter what hell yeah
yeah Bishop before with tempo and then
the bishop comes c1 but this is a game
of tension which is really instructive
for amateurs all those of you watching
the show who aren't grandmasters which
as many of you just notice how the
players block key areas like the
second-ranked they don't trade you have
to be willing to stare down your
opponent in critical areas same with the
pawns right often amateurs give away too
many access points to their opponent by
being the first to break the tension the
first to blink and trade so the reason
why we're seeing these maneuverings the
Queen come in to h4 and then back up
right the bishop come in and back up is
because neither side really wants to
give if white trades on d5 it's always a
horrible decision it weakens the pawns
and strengthen blacks position but if
black trades then he's opening up the
bishop on g2 and opening the D file so
just wanted to elaborate on those
instructive Bobby Hess comments he makes
so offhandedly he just gives out wisdom
of pearls that like dimes a dime-a-dozen
you just you just hand them out like
you're the Oprah of free pearls of
wisdom I mean seriously the but that's
why we're seeing the maneuvers so
despite the draw and despite the
frustration we now have his fans neither
side wanted to give tension I'm a little
with you Robert there now it feels like
these games are getting a little bit
these guys are calling it early a little
too quickly but but okay I just wanted
to highlight the reason why you see top
players maneuver and build on tension
and not not blink so to speak is because
you're almost always conceding something
and everyone watching the show can learn
from that yeah quick shout-out to
Ibrahim I think it was 1995 for
subscribing to the channel there you go
Danny I'm gonna do it for you this time
they're giving people and we are in our
960 game and if I'm corrected these
players have not seen this opening with
the starting position yes unlike last
year those who've been following chest
comm for a while you know in the first
speech s championship we let the players
know that chefs 960 positions so they
could prepare it but then it turned out
Sasha Grichuk was the only one who
prepared and he's swept chess960 the
other that was bad but we decided it was
more fun to always Surprise them
shout out to our last seven I gotta tell
Eric Hansen is a babe who said you can
surmise that GM's have above-average
memory and the visual visual spatial
abilities I don't know if that's a real
word or if you did that just to make me
sound silly reading it but either way to
Shea yeah I mean gems of good memories
for sure but I think they're often
sometimes are not specific memories more
general pattern the strategic ideas but
you know I come back to the 960 before I
go off on a tangent you know look what
cardiac in his daddy Castle queenside
both sides did you know it moves can be
one because there was a problem with the
long diagonal and so with 94 yeah why
can and does capture an e4 I think black
is hoping that now the there's not that
many pieces on the White King side which
is the Queen side of the board 7f takes
e4 officially I was gonna say or take a
omission nice back to c3 the idea
everybody is I think what Robert was
about to highlight is to worry about the
black Queen coming to a3 and the knight
coming to b4 right but this is changing
that yeah this prevents that but the
same time if you look at this backward
epon you're not happy about that with
white so BL exactly v played and already
look at this there's a backup on e - if
you take on e5 you're left with an
isolated pawn I guess you could consider
what's the consideration you're taking I
think white maybe shoots efore and at
some point trying to trying to eliminate
the weakness of this e pawn and and
maybe even open up the F file and the
bishop but right now he can't do it
because probably black can just capture
it okay queen of two games a tempo on a7
so don't forget that
but now Kuryakin you're right he needs
to do something quickly because if black
recordin eights and the pieces come to
the e-file
white is just positionally worse for the
rest of the game with this backward e
city to pawn and for those who just
tuning in the bish 1a 8 is not in a
legal position
it was sixty chests and the bishop
started there look you know it's very
suspicious but that's kind of how this
game works but now I mean Danny so he
takes a knee five he goes Rudi four so
he's trying to play AS before yeah he's
all right he's trying to get e four so
that that pawn doesn't become weak
that's it that's it that's an idea to
eliminate a piece that is trying to
prepare to get rid of White's position
of weakness so that's why he Caro
invites that trade but but maybe the
more pieces come off the board the less
likely you believe that that either
sides gonna have real winning chances
here and now what that weakness being
traded I feel like we are we are about
to see that we're gonna be heading into
the three minute portion Robert with the
exact score we see above all the cameras
here with a five and a half to four game
four and a half game lead or six to five
a full point lead for Nakamura yeah I
mean this position yes white has doubled
pawns but those actually this one
actually protects the king and unless
something really terrible happened I
mean he too is played well something
terrible happens there's no way to make
progress because the four on four on the
Queen side
yeah it's double pawns with us you can't
make any right no problem
you got to be able to target very often
the weakness of double pawns is not just
the pause themselves but what they've
left behind too if you have minor pieces
and things you can take advantage of
these types of squares so that's why we
look at the position and you see he karo
has even just offered a draw and wow
that is that is maybe the the strangest
ending to a match Robert that I started
out it started out so decisive right
only decisive games and and really
aggressive play we had a lot of draws to
bring the five-minute portion to a close
before you get too upset and going to
rant about what you feel the
responsibility should be of these
players to play more decisive chess just
what are your thoughts with Accardo
taking a one-game lead into the
three-minute portion I think in cars
playing better there were some moments
where I felt like that game in
particular that ended up in a draw where
there was like that Bishop takes h7
check blunder thing that actually turned
out to be pretty good for black right I
think his moments and yes it's the
scores +1 for a car who's 6 to 5 but I
think he had an opportunity to go +2 i
they know is based on the level of play
I've seen I think that might be kind of
where
man I'm a him not gonna be sir get
enough credit cuz even in that game that
Sergei was much better but from I just
feel maybe she's instinctively that
Hikaru is playing better than Sergei at
this moment shoutout to the chess couch
you just subscribed yet another awesome
chess streamer everyone should go to
twitch TV slash the chess couch and
subscribe so let's talk about our stats
everyone asks well we don't have the
full details of our algorithm revealed
and kind of the way we sort of come at
these decisions give them ratings but
our estimation heading into the match
Robert was the cardiac and be the 5:2
favorite and was that he would have a a
potential chance to get a lead into five
two that would be where he should be
better
we know Nakamura is a stud and bullets
so according to according to that you
would you we look at where the match
prediction currently is and that's why
you see the graph kind of the way the
way we do where we feel the match is
sliding Nakamura section because
according to us the with both these
players in the performance ratings they
bring in Cory Aachen failing to get a
lead in the longer time controls is is
really shifting the percentage of this
match being won by Nakamura back in his
direction we're gonna take one quick
break it's about 45 seconds to get a
word here from our sponsors for those of
you who don't know garry kasparov
smashed ur class course is officially
live go to master class comm slash chess
check out garry kasparov scores it's
awesome
it provides I've now seen it it is
exactly what they said Robert really for
tournament ambitious tournament players
but then some awesome
interesting stuff from his childhood
some positions that he's shown that were
his favorites and some some great stuff
so let's let's check out one of the the
clips they gave us this isn't the
trailer you've all seen on YouTube this
is a newer clip right before the 3
minute portion starts I'm here to share
with you my knowledge of the game of
chess it's not just tracks and attacks
you have to be creative check and now we
can look at few studies when changing
pieces could lead to a decided Vantage
for one side or to be a defensive
mechanism to save the game that looks
otherwise desperate why does an extra
piece but our poon is under attack and
our mic is under attack in the middle
game or in the opening you definitely
have to pay attention to this threat
because night is more valuable at a poem
but with an end game
so protecting the night doesn't do us
any good if we protect the night and
black takes the pawn that's a
surrendered wrong position rook and
Knight cannot win against alone but how
can we benefit from keeping this pawn
alive a trick is that we play a quiet
move a3 doesn't seem logical black
simply takes the knight with a check but
then King b2 and surprise surprise the
rook there are so many moves cannot
avoid the exchange if rooks goes back on
h1 or g1l group d1 will change rooks and
our pawn is unstoppable
but instead of moving to the first rack
with h1 or g1 like who can go back to a
4 and then we understand why our poor
moved down to a 4 but to a3 sometimes
very important you make just a small
move one square but
it has devastating effect because this
poem protects square before and after
loop III check King goes on C - or a -
doesn't matter then we'll go through
before and rook black rook is trapped
technically is not trapped because like
an exchange rule either taking one
before and after a before alphorn is
unstoppable or moving crew kanji for and
then after exchange our pawn is again
stopped and that's one of the lessons of
this endgame and we'll see how many more
endgame lessons we get with these two
guys taking early draws unfortunately we
haven't had as many as we'd like but
back the show is back on the road thanks
everybody for supporting our sponsors
checking out masterclass comm slash
chess and for sitting by and checking
out that trailer as we now head into the
three minute portion robert moore b3 b3
all day apparently that's exactly what
Hikaru wants a good record so far in the
match so you might as well continue the
opening that's leading to decisive games
in his favor I don't like the position
as it stands for white strategically
speaking yes you have the two bishops
but look at the pawn structure right the
double F pawns can really come back to
bite if you know things okay look at
this a3 b3 c3 d3 not exactly what you're
looking for from white but at the same
time and eventually you can go B for
perhaps and push on that side the board
or you're just seeing what black is
doing in the in the interim but Danny I
mean I really prefer the black pawn
structure and the ability for black to
break on the Queen side here I agree I
think that the bishop here can't be
underestimated in the long term but we
saw this last game the last time they
had this structure Hikaru wasn't able to
get anything and they ended up just kind
of sitting tight with those rooks
staring each other down on e 2 and a 2
so it's one of the positions where we
like the bishop pair strategically
everybody when when you think that most
positions eventually become open but
with black having such a solid structure
here with east 6 and d5 and c6 it's just
so hard
for white to properly pry open space
which means that that's Robert saying
black is now gonna start getting that
activity he got on the queenside the
last time they had this position and I'm
gonna make a prediction here we saw that
car yakin went away from the London when
hikaru had a couple games back to back
that really showed that he was gonna be
just fine against this London since then
we've really seen Sergei played nothing
but e for if Sergei holds this game
again and is again in the driver's seat
I'm gonna bet that Hikaru abandons b3 at
least for a game or two and tries tries
his hand at something else yeah I mean
he's not getting a good position I think
what you said is very very important
here you we love to bishops we love
bishops in open space
look at the bishop on g2 it's staring
down at pawns
yeah a pot ass c 6d v e6 at all protect
the square and b5 and the bishop would
you choose not really getting anything
open and now look at this the rook came
to be for a force hanging c4 is hanging
f4 might be hanging shortly the Rope can
just double on the B file or in the D
file I mean why not you can now put XE
force oh yeah even with this being about
a minute time advantage for hit car on
the clock and of course everybody you're
now noticing we have switched to the
faster time control I I still think this
is this has been a been a win for Sergei
out of the opening and and maybe he cara
will will consider switching up yeah
1985 is a nice move i think you almost
okay you don't have to take that night
but now you have the knight and the rook
bit ganging up on f4 as long as black
can find a way to unpin that night and
keep the c-pawn alive he's gonna be the
only one who can win this game why not
just play c5 just push the pawn okay
plays rook c8 I think c5 was also just
fine for black and carry out of the b3
opening yeah no this is I mean isn't
black just like what up a pawn right now
f4 is weak a4 is weak blacks more active
is there anything positive I can say for
whites position not especially so yeah
this is just kind of perfect play by car
yakin and as you mentioned I think it's
time for Hikaru to play more kind of
more challenging openings because right
Sergei getting everything he wanted in
this game yep Hikaru plays a5 which
the best thing to do when you have a
horrible you know dead duckling pollen
is try to push it and create weaknesses
in your opponent's position but but it
doesn't really faze Sergey he just
ignores it I'm not even gonna take this
thing and open up my king you can take
either one of my pawns and I'll easily
take back black is just focused on the C
pawn I think we're gonna see a big win
here for Sergey which is what he needs
not just to even the score but he hasn't
won and and really more than more than I
don't want to say ninety minutes but
it's been at least an hour and 20
minutes right because Sergei won early
in the match everybody he won the first
game but he hasn't won a game since is
that tree it's one win for Sergey at
this point two for a card I'm pretty
sure and then a whole a whole boatload
of draws and I think if my math is
correct wow yeah this this is hat if
Surya does not win this game he's in big
trouble because the opposition is
winning you have a passed pawn and extra
pawn and I mean yeah this is gonna be
heartbreaking for Surya if he can't pull
this one out but ya know I think he will
though because this is right up his
alley - as far as good old good
old-fashioned Russian family fun right
this is a Russian school boys know how
to convert themselves an extra pawn and
I say that jokingly but everybody
obviously we know that Sergei is just a
super solid very technical very accurate
player so you expect him to win when he
has this kind of clear extra C pawn
advantage right something but the
opening lady they've both played several
openings multiple times including the
London and here we've seen this b3 on
the first move and I think that what
Hakkar has been doing is beginning
dynamic positions and he's won several
of them but as we see the down side is
that because the position is so dynamic
that in fact car yakin can seize the
upper hand if you miss play is white on
the other hand in the London system I
felt that
Sergei I almost said Magnus Sergei isn't
really getting anything ok well what's
going on here yeah he just allowed isn't
Knight h3 check can get you a queen up
for check just trade Queens and game
over the C pawn falls at the end of the
line does it oh you thought he had rook
d4
but maybe he doesn't am I wrong yeah
okay so that I think that was a Karl's
idea yeah he does have before
oh yeah actually this is now and this is
not so easy mace in over your c3 Brooke
at foresee to you trade yeah this yeah I
think that was the trick as he sort of
maybe swindled Sergei into that line
because he had to he had an idea in the
end and I think we're gonna get exactly
that line we just analyzed and well now
okay it's still a position where black
is playing for two results and an extra
pawn is is a good pun but but Brooke
endings are more drawn than almost any
other ending so this is this is a
practical win if you're Hikaru just to
even get here who and now there's a
third of rook b5 watch out everybody fun
that wasn't I got to show you this line
in the analysis board if King g6 was
played rook b5 and a trade would
actually lead to white winning the
endgame because the past pawn transition
so that was a little salty Carla Sarah
yeah disagree because the a pawn Queens
the same time the beat pawn does but yes
but still still we're gonna draw yep
yeah you have to be very aware of those
things but now the rook on a7 is very
active black can't really make progress
unless the King somehow makes it over to
the Queen side which is doing its best
effort here you know I mean it gave
relief or you lose the f6 pawn so that's
not gonna be winning but one of the
problems with f5 is sometimes there's
like f4 check which sacrifices a pawn
but forces a bad structure then you have
double def poems which are more useless
than than any other kind of healthy
extra pawn so watch out for watch out
for a move like that to come if black it
black steps they came back to g5 okay
Corey Aachen doesn't he goes the other
way and now you can be careful if you're
hey car at some point rook d3 giving up
the a pawn with d3 as the threats if the
king was a gun g6 orange e5 rook d3
would be a good move so somehow sir he
needs some maneuvers King out but is he
he's not moving the Queen sides he's
he's gonna end up giving up probably at
least one of his King side pawns and may
it's a good strategy because you have
Rick f6 for example we're gonna six f4
check and then rip d4 follows yeah you
get the coupon so this is a good good
opportunity here by Sergei and that's
the right over yo rookie six is the
right place for it because black can't
afford to give up both King side pawns
just for the a pawn you you know you
laughs for jagrata for intake and the
problem then is here kingi for rib
before group takes e5 rook takes rook f5
and yep
king king of five I guess also works the
Brooke can't move off the fourth-ranked
without dropping the pawn can't move off
the fifth-ranked without dropping the
ape on everybody sona car was still well
within drawing territory can Sergei step
forward and allow the rook trade f4
falls the a pawn rushes probably that's
just a draw
okay we're up me right okay but white
takes first I guess that's the simplest
simplest road to a draw here so a slight
a slightly disappointing start to
three-minute if you're Sergei that he's
gonna fail he's gonna fail to get a win
where he was much better and even the
score was black but but still right in
the match it's a one game lead of course
everyone including myself predicting
Kokoro to get better as the bullet nears
but but you also aren't aren't terribly
upset if you're Sergei that it's a close
match right now
yeah those are the black pieces right so
you know generally speaking favorite the
white move first you dictate the course
of the game
so Sergei is very much in it but that
was a position where you know he wins
that game like 98 times out of 100 right
like that was so winning at a certain
point it's got to be disappointing but
you have to throw it out the window
forget about it just play this game and
he received is very popular at the high
GM level with this isolated pawn for
black so for those of you out there who
you know really are afraid of isolated
pawns yeah they kind of stink because
you can't protect it with another pawn
and the pawns best friend is another one
at the same time black gets a lot of
dynamic play here 94 I've seen played
it's like yeah here comes Knight d4
exactly and okay the point was if you
took on d4 than the mission at forth
fell and still black is left with this
isolated pawn but why spawn to the Queen
side are a bit overextended and blackest
at some point threatening rook d8
probably d4 is in the cards so why he's
gonna continue to prevent d4 from
happening and even if d4 does happen
white off it can ignore it by playing
efore than f4 and just expanding on the
King side so yeah this is a this is
again a kind of a small grinded out
advantage for white if if you can get an
ideal setup moves like Bishop e2 Bishop
of three get a rook on the D file
ganging up against the D pawn white
white should be able to press here for a
long time yeah
cars got a lot of time though yeah he's
very familiar with these positions I've
seen them in his games before but you
know while he may have a lot of time his
little cramped and he just wanted work
to dat so he's saying okay I'm gonna
cede control over the C file and said
try to plate or and again
Sergei stops and you're d4 now you
actually just blunder upon because d4
law is a takes d4 and there's a
discovery bishop h7 check if you capture
again on d4 so it's important always to
keep in mind but instead now Hakan
removes his other rook to C a which is a
very good timing because yeah White's
ricochet on C 1 and B 1 in order to
compete for the D file why he had to go
over c1 d1 and now for a to c8 if you
have rook c1 now you allow finally d4 a
trade on 1 and then go d4 so a very nice
play by hikaru precise and now black is
taking over it's always what happens in
these positions you still are left with
an isolated pawn but once you start
controlling that C file and put some
pressure on the a3 pawn black is the one
I think who starts to take over this
game right
yeah it's it's an instructive point
everything we've been highlighting about
what centers around the d4 pawn break
right is black can I get d4 or access to
the C file and control the board or is
white gonna be able to put a
stranglehold on that and eventually play
moves like a four rook d4 Bishop a3 and
kind of gang up on that d5 pawn so it's
it's an instructive dynamic and balanced
whenever you have these isolated Queen
pausing and good experience for
everybody to play when both sides really
want to very different things in the
position rook a 4 is an interesting move
so why didn't he go for the more
traditional like a 4 and then try to
play a move like rook d4 and kind of
double on the default like I was saying
yeah I guess he figured that black would
size CeBIT move the other up to the C
file and if the bishop wants f3 then
black goes like rook a3 or rook C for
somebody bat and just you take my D pawn
I take your a pawn let's call it a draw
so instead he went rook a4
the rook is weirdly placed that's not a
space you normally see a rook like kind
of just in front of a pawn it's you know
it does attack a7 but a cellphone is
obviously well defended and I don't know
I mean I think that realistically black
is the only one who can get some
pressure here now like if you exactly
rook B to rook c7 or other group - C - I
guess if black does any white trades and
okay now they're not to row so I wasn't
say black just written d5 the rook would
come to f5 and in time of the risk now
with the King coming up is if the King
gets to e5 everybody and sort of
relieves the rook of his duties of
having to guard this pawn look for that
rook to quickly grab the C file and try
to get some counter play so but if Y
tries to prevent that with ever trying
to grab the C file first and black will
immediately strike with D for trade and
then the rook on d4 will be hitting the
b4 pawn so starting to see that that
black is gonna get the King active gonna
get d4 and probably be the one with
winning chances against the weak be
pawns although I guess now if d4 comes
in the bishop can sometimes sit on c6
which makes this rook kind of irritated
about having to guard this a7 one yeah
and black is definitely better here
because the king is very nicely
centralized I would have started with
King e5 instead of rushing with d4 but
okay okay seven rook takes before Bishop
e2
I think knew a Bishop to c6 maybe
there's some Bishop c4 stuff where I
rate a seven here maybe a seven before
Bishop e2 and and then and kind of hold
the endgame that way it looks like
that's kind of where he's headed yeah
and I guess Bishop d5 check can be a bit
annoying you have to be just to be
careful if you're white you know because
Bishop c6 as I was saying runs into
Bishop c4 and the promise of rook b7
Bishop takes b5 there is no roof takes B
6 because Bishop F 1 check then picks up
that rook on d6 so you have to be very
careful here and I think you know bug is
going up a clean pawn so whether you're
not you've seen what it is a pawn
yeah a pawn is upon everybody to show
that line Robert was talking about rook
b7 Bishop b5 rook p6 it's not the trade
that works but the discovery on f1 check
and then the gobbling of the rook so
with that tactic in mind
white is uh
going down a pawn but okay you have a
rook on the seventh rank you're also
ideally placed already we always know
you want your Brooks behind pawns and
rook endings so white does have decent
drawing chances here and there we see
active defense from the Minister of
Defense he's not just gonna sit and let
himself be ground down by the extra
pollen he's gonna try to create some
counter blood Danny I was gonna say
instead of Bishop takes me five Singh
maybe good one rook takes b5 and the
idea of being Bishop takes b5 there then
Bishop d5 check and you play a bishop
ending rather than a rook ending I think
in the bishop ending you have pretty
good chances to win that yeah that was a
really critical missed opportunity there
from mcaro because if he doesn't go on
to win the rook ending then this little
this nice little combination the big
reason everybody is because the Bishop
ending is the Brooke rooks are just so
so much better at defending when you're
just down a single pawn with active play
but here here the LightSquared Bishop is
not the best defender so I agree with
you Robert that's a really nice that's a
clippable moment clip that for us twitch
that's a missed opportunity there by
Hikaru potentially to win this game yeah
now he's yeah and this is a well known
ending right this has been these haven't
played many many times the problem for
black is the only way to really push the
pawn is to eventually move your King
towards the Queen side but really right
now why can cut off the King so you'll
have to sack pawn at the very least to
get the King over there and then white
you know tens have enough compensation
in the form of two-on-one and you
sacrifice the rook and make a drubbing
right now
let's see you know we're gonna start
doing just a pure count right yeah I
mean but if that's it has to be played
here why could okay I could give check
first and then or even play h5 or h6 g5
and there's just you're not gonna have
okay the F file being open sometimes
creates those long-term opportunities
for sort of a backdoor rook trick by
black but if white if white gets active
counter play quickly enough there's just
no way blacks gonna be able to convert
with just this extra pawn and here comes
this King who's gonna hide on the F file
I think I know he won't have time now
after b3 right if black had not played
b3 white might have tried King III King
II for King of five-o now we might be
getting close into that closer to that
winning territory
I mean I guess you just shuffle back and
forth it should be yeah I'm surprised by
that oh he wants to play out for okay I
was gonna say Brooke to be six seemed to
make a little I was wondering if rookie
six trying to poke at the Kings side but
okay well not yet
oh what's happened here yeah this King
what yeah he's he's lost now he's
definitely lost yeah how did he how did
even miss play that there though is that
it was that yeah he just come he got his
King stuck well what is this yeah I
don't know what he was doing there now
he's obviously lost but I mean he kind
of got his King Stach has him cut off
and then he thought that it may have you
got f4 in you can make a draw but the
problem is you just allowed the trade
the king goes in quickly and you can't
get to g5 quick enough so that was an
instantly instructive point and that's
something sir he will be regretting
because yeah he had a class I'm Mitchell
he's holding that game absolutely I mean
there's definitely the easier endgame to
hold is the brook ending there compared
to the bishop ending so I don't think
that changes your evaluation from
earlier but what what was the
instructive takeaway from that did white
just create too many weaknesses there on
the Kings side with h4 and f3 and a for
sure white have sits at tight or is it
or is it the opposite should have been
more aggressive sometimes I think that
what's tricky to understand is are you
already in a theoretical draw and so you
should be not changing anything or do
you need to do something to simplify the
position before that that black King
eventually wanders over to the Queen
side I think that's the difficult
decision a lot of people have to make
there
hold on seem to have lost Robert there
for a second so the yes so that there
you are now you're back I'm muting
myself my accent go if it happens what
were you saying what did you say to the
answer my work any question you muted
yourself okay that's very funny I was
just saying that you know you want to go
h5 and fix that weakness on h6 right
from like them but the same time you're
worried that the king is still running
over and you're not in time to go rook
h7 takes the pawn because you can't get
back to the Queen side in time so it's
definitely instructive I very much
recommend all people were trying to get
better a chest to put that position on
the board you're Debra at skis end game
manual well you know you can work
through that and not just the manual but
you know there are many sources to go
through an ending like that but it's
very helpful so I'm just looking at the
answer and the solution how to draw
right to go through my step process and
what Denny you know going to this game
for a second again we see a b3 stuff and
his run b2 is not the happiest
piece in the world and now retreated to
c1 but from here just optically like c5
here from black I just yeah open up
chisel large squares start to create
some counter play or even prepare it
first you can play Brooke 88 if you want
I don't think c5 is going anywhere if
you're worried about the d5 pawn and I
think what you were getting to there is
I agree I don't think Accardo is getting
a lot out of b3 but he's not going away
from it yet right and you have to like
black chances here with the open White
King eventually maybe these dark squares
become a critical point as Queen g3 move
now after Bishop e3 no I guess we're
kept three would have saved the day okay
but a car oh I thought Oh kind of
scowling guy I don't think he likes this
position either and this move Knight c8
heading to d6 and efore seems like a
pretty clear and straightforward plan
for black I got I got to give done X for
me shout out on the twitch at let Lee
says laughs Matt my LMAO wow I almost
said that loud set up a chest position
on the board you think any of us
actually take chess seriously we're just
here for the banter that's not true I
think there's a lot of chess fans in the
chat but yes no setting is saying
telling somebody hey do some hard work
at a chess board they're like what right
on that note also a shout-out to twitch
twitch chat user prime Gordon Manley who
said who said that we were all we're all
welcome he called this draw a while back
but it didn't end up being a draw right
at Caro ended up winning there so he
said he it was easy to predict a draw
because he has an IQ of 176 but I think
I think he was proven wrong there so
alright the the King side is opening up
and with it I just have to love blacks
chances and I have to come back to what
we've been touting that Ricardo is not
getting anything with b3 and I'm
surprised he hasn't switched up shout
out to Andrew Hatfield thank you for the
sub buddy thank you for the sub yeah
what is I mean I can't keep doing this
to himself
there's no one to blame but himself
right and we say this a lot we ought to
take responsibility for our actions but
look at the position he's down upon
right as Bishamon who is still stuck
facing a nice little brick wall on the
p7 of d5 chain black can just move easy
Queen it's a great move threatening
Queen e3 check the other threatening
three to double with the tempo yeah
really ugly position from whites point
of view III if I was playing a real game
like a that real game a slow game a
classical game Irish islands I just say
you know what I'm dead lost here
nothing's going on cuz rip g3 just 94
giving me more space and rerouting that
night as ugly shadow to donks for me who
just subscribed on Twitch and also prime
cat daddy moon another cat name says
Hess is a top notch commentator it'd be
nice to see him do some Sinquefield cub
coverage or other major events Robert
there you go getting some love in the
twitch chat buddy I mean no that's if we
go not that we don't disagree obviously
we know you're a prime top notch
commentator um I just you know
appreciate the fans right there the way
okay what is going on Quincy one check
Quincy one check has resigned times
followed by the brook falling and
Ricardo shakes his head that's a twit
that's a clippable moment somebody
clipped me a good at karo
shakes his head number two blundering
give me a give me a good clip there with
a Caro blundering of rook that's too bad
for her Carl but hate that was a huge
win sir guys first win we predicted he
might get it remember a few games ago
but he didn't now Sergei gets his first
win since the first game of the match
right there and look how quickly Sergei
he's moving now he's just
is blitzing out this opening here and
we're in the London system we've seen
this before back to one night in a
previous game and here he goes again
and his point just to prevent e5 and I
think he's on to something here Hikaru
is a very dynamic player not to say not
very talented and positional chest is
not all what I mean but my point he
prefers dynamic chest right being good
at going and even if it's you know the
engine might say he's worse he feels
right confident that he's gonna out
calculate his opponent right and what
Barry keeps doing time and time again is
he's bottling up the position look at
this where can blackie an activity you
want to go a five you're left with an
isolated pawn
so instead sergei developing naturally
you get rookie one eventually he can go
Bishop f4 he's done this in a previous
game yeah well not just a previous game
Robert this is the only game he want was
on the white side of the London with the
g3 I think it's easy for other get cuz
we're seeing dozens of games but this
was the game that Sergei one was in this
exaction his way he won was when a car I
went early f5 they had this but it was
that same approach from white in regards
to the thing keto in me in the London
yes you're right Hikaru
Ricardo didn't play well in that line
when he extended a five but as far as
White's approach is the same yes and I
think actually the game that Hakkar
ended up drawing was in this position
but he was worth it might be the same
exact position yeah right like he went
eventually somehow it was in exchange
sacrifice I believe that was the game
but ended up in a draw but white was
doing very very well there so I know may
I'm mixing up my games a point being
this current position it's very
difficult for black to see counter play
you've met okay he's might try for b5
okay what does b5 do it opens up the a
file for whites I can put it on it also
does create the minority attack idea
right we always have to highlight them
when you have this open file black has
the two on three okay white puts the
clamps on the b4 idea by the way that's
crucial because we were just talking
about the minority attack everybody but
yeah now I really like white again
Robert I liked before because the the VA
file and the bishop are meeting over
here on on the light squares well there
it is you went to a5 I was recommending
taking on b5 first because if you taking
took on b5 before going before the
Knights HP 5 doesn't
there's no actual price then before that
would sink this pond is a weakness on
the light scores there and you didn't
even need before often you go Knight b3
to c5 because there is a hole there so
right now I think that Y has be very
careful because we see that of course
the quantity 3 is under attack but if
you go Bishop takes b5 rook takes b5 it
reminds me of kind of a position you've
seen a Capablanca game where material is
level both sides that would have five
pawns each but black is better because
look at the pawn chains that there's a
target on c3 it was the bit of the pawn
chain that's what's essential the base
of the pawn chain from black is f7 which
is very very very difficult to attack
the base of the pawn chain for white is
c3 just quite simple to put pressure on
it in fact you can't go c4 because
that's completely under control so this
is much better for black I don't care
what the engine says black is
significantly better here yeah from a
point of view and for the record
everybody that put that pawn there was
poison due to the h7 square shout-out to
I think it was anonymous bystander I
missed your username sorry buddy but
thank you for the sub thanks to all the
support on Twitch everybody and all our
premium members in the chess TV chat ok
well black is gonna grind it out now and
try to Rima new ver himself I I hear you
the black is the only one who can win
this type of game because the only real
positional weakness on the board is the
c3 pawn you highlighted the difference
between c3 and f7 but I guess for black
now he has to find a way to deal with
some of these threats the poking that
white is doing on the Kings side he's
just gonna trade Queens I guess and then
reorganize his efforts to gang up on c3
yeah and quick shout-out to Kappa Blanco
with the K and the twitch chat who said
Hess I'm here that's very funny
God is always watching yeah but Daniel
how do you defend is white you have to
do some sort of passion you have to try
to get c4 I think I think you have to
try to trade off that weakness and and
simplify the position by yeah and he and
he go I think that's the right idea cuz
even if you lose the D pawn now you're
at least are in an endgame where you've
got this three on four on one side of
the board and maybe y can hold I think
the main thing that'll come back to bite
cardiac and is the fact that this H pawn
is so extended right it yeah hey Carlo
just gobbles it up so I agree with you I
think black is
black is in the driver's seat but 45
white push inside the 5 then rook rook
deef rook before go after the deep one
Bishop I wonder like Bishop a6 c6 but
should be 7 and that shouldn't work out
honestly but this is good
still good winning chances for black
yeah of course because only you're gonna
be up if you win this deep on especially
normally it's your output one pawn the
promise your two pawns here and it looks
like I was in using inappropriate word
bad Double H pawns but you can go H 5 H
4 and break the punch not sure
white so also you we should highlight
the other reason that black has winning
chances as the night versus the bishop
dynamic right normally everybody we know
the bishop is a better minor piece when
you have a race position in the endgame
pawns on both sides of the board when
you have a knight who can rima new ver
himself poke at the light scores poke at
the dark squares back and forth back and
forth and create and gang up on
weaknesses the Knights ability to
outmaneuver the bishop is what makes a
single side of the board focus much
better for the night so a Accardo traded
here but even though I was just
highlighting the Knights advantage of
the bishop you have to like that for
black because it takes away the
weaknesses of these doubled H pawns
right now you probably miss d5 and you
saw he just sat back he was he was
frustrated that he missed that Robert
you saw it on the Kouros face Ryan he
wanted to capture you know ideal you
capture the pawn on d5 and create a
passed pawn now the problem is look at
the three on two White's pawn f2 covers
the e pawn so it's a passed pawn that
isn't a clear pass pawn right so you
know it's not it's unopposed by an enemy
palm but still it's not it you wouldn't
really consider it a passed pawn I guess
the right point so it's much easier for
whites to defend the endgame then let's
say you throw that east six pawn on d5
put the rook behind it that's very
difficult as we saw in the previous game
where hikaru 1 black because you have to
distract the King over to the Queen side
and it's difficult for whites and defend
them now it's easy because white its
King is on the same side of its pond
which means that the task of just
shuffling your pieces and making sure
you don't blunder is much more civil now
I don't want to oversimplify here black
still has good chances because I you
know should be a draw but if you have
this only pawn dynamic which is
different than just a if this poem was
on the chief file is simple three on two
that you're black does have the chances
of the
we're seeing Hikaru go for shadow
chicharrón is carrying who just
subscribed on Twitch only 30 minutes
remaining exactly in the three-minute
portion before we take another quick
break break in the bullet so if you're
just joining us you have you're tuning
in for what you thought this would be a
very very close match it is only a one
game separation we're gonna have
fireworks by the end of the day folks
don't go anywhere and call your friends
and ask them what they're doing with
their Saturday la beans thanks for
subscribing buddy what's that for III
Danny that's what at some point you have
to consider this a crazy III bring the
king in right III fe3 in King e for the
problem is you don't have many pawns
remaining so after something like at e3
pawn takes you three key before there's
always gonna be some sort of room g6 and
just you know tickle that F pawn so you
know what he goes for it f3 here comes
the chaos it's not enough not enough
he's just doing his best and he'll
probably play king of three anywhere
here not take e3 yeah he goes for that
best Ritchie section uh should do the
trick yeah Corey Aachen or sorry hick
hey car I'm not gonna have enough here
and Corey Alcon leaning back a little
bit and karu knows that should be a draw
takes f6 with check and after King takes
e3 I wouldn't be surprised if they just
agree sir Kuryakin is actually offered a
draw in the game chat on chess calm and
hey Karl thinking about it apparently so
pawns are so terrible and rook end games
you know it seems counterintuitive
because it's a call to rook pawn it is
your rooks pawn well they're so bad just
very upsetting because you can't make
any progress with that cuz you can't
force the King to one side the king is
in the corner and you can't not get out
of there so a nice hold by cardiac and
he managed to escape that one nezam you
must draw because he's only stealing at
one point we see again this b3 stuff but
is a different dynamic of the position
looks more like a d4 opening so we're
back kind of into a normal territory
though I'm very curious to see how
Hikaru plans just he sees any sort of
initiative because he just his
continuously gun what I considered poor
with white and it's not what you would
like to do is good for bullet chess
honestly because you know your plans
very well and he's just so used to it
but with three minutes five minutes on
the clock it's just not going very well
agree totally and I I'm I'm not sure if
it karo feels like there's just more
uncharted territory here perhaps the
reason he's sticking with this approach
Robert is just because he wants to make
sure he's poked and prodded at every
possible b3 area before he gets to
Bullock is in the bullet portion they
were lying even more on intuition and
less less concrete less preparation than
than any other section of the match
right so maybe a car which is still
trying to work his way around things but
but I wouldn't be surprised if he just
sticks would be three and then totally
flips and bullet and goes with something
else oh I think he will and and the kind
of shock factor will also be important
the bullet where it's like you're
expecting the same opening every time
and often BAM you're hit with like a
Sicilian yep how you got to think on
your toes shout out Rick go ahead to all
the guests the movers Luca 0:07
Giorgio leo our boy our boys miss la
fizz in there
Smith la fans so shout out to everybody
playing guess to move on chest comm
sorry Robert go ahead no you're good
Smiths I was upset that I saw him at
Cobham Blanca and he's like well I was
world champion too you may have had some
attention but in this position I was
going to talk about the structure here
yeah the only weakness any eye it's hard
to call it a weakness currently is this
pawn on c64 black right so an idea for
white is to somehow you know throw in
1985 and just permanently are now on d4
even yeah hit that pop thanks now it
looks like that knight on e5 is coming
to c4 which is a great square right it's
pretty well-protected not anymore
none of that cover 0 yet but yeah
they're beating me to the punch here and
the point now is that yes in open space
we like our bishops however current
given the current dynamics of the
position that mission on e7
the best it will do is trade for a
knight like if you go Bishop f6 and
straight on on d4 it has no future yeah
that said you know what isn't doing much
either because that is a good strategy
from blacks perspective is okay maybe I
can get go now Knight d7 Bishop f6
instead even rook e8 oh just trying to
avoid 19 b5 and yes
there was maybe a little trick coming
here with Knight takes b5 everybody in
for King the Queen and rook so sir
someone else's ion right even if it's
not foking anything a sacrifice could be
in the works there where you get to pass
pawns in the Queen side so here we see I
was just like I say speaking of which
did he just misses chance of something
like Knight takes B 5 and 9 takes d5 I
guess it doesn't work immediately
because the knight still guards f6 but
but yeah this this this idea of
something nasty happening on the light
square pause even at the cost of a piece
could be there for white and now I hate
blacks position yeah yes now they may be
this 9nh you goes to see 1 2 B 3 285
right find other ways to double up
against that point yeah I think black
just was Bishop g7 king of Fayette
Keaney 7 etc but why I say I hate it in
this current position black is gonna
hold I think that I don't see a way for
white to make the necessary progress
especially the King quickly come in to
d7 but blacks Bishop has no real future
and is not a bright future and I always
in the endgame I'm always nervous that
when I don't have a plan and my opponent
has different ideas to push forward that
I'm gonna make a mistake right and
become the victim of a you know kind of
a unfortunate defeat and so here like we
already look like if black does capture
on d4 well then okay now I can capture
in d4 enclose everything but as a
caption before the King comes in d4 now
the King can try to get to the e5 square
right of course okay this is just now
just a lot of hugely closed position so
you can do nothing isn't you shuffle
your pieces but yeah and they and they
will probably agree to yet another
peaceful result I'm not exactly sure
what the stats are on how many peaceful
results we have in these matches but I
feel like there's been a lot of draws
today
shoutout to Jinger GM the one and only
Simon Williams who just subscribed and
there's Grandmaster robert Hess who has
just gifted a subscription or subscribed
himself I'm not sure what you do Robert
I'm not telling you okay well I'm gonna
I'm gonna guess you subscribed yourself
if you say that but anyway make sure
that you follow go to twitch TV slash
GMR lh2 and twitchtv ginger GM to follow
both Simon and raw
were launched on twitch ah look at that
so clearly clearly it's chess BAE I
think gifting everybody cuz I just
subscribed and I did not just subscribe
go ahead I was gonna say I'm Knight 64
King takes d4 I mean no no 94 84 what am
I talking about and the King just runs
over the King side so Knight trades have
to be carefully considered so I think
there's only you have to move your
knight here I came with your King
anywhere you can't take on d4 because ii
takes d4 and the King runs over to the
Kings side so that leaves let's say
Knight C seven or eight g7 yeah I don't
made 92 to f4 is there I guess there's
no real way to make progress but that's
my earlier point these players made it
seem so simple it's so it's just
straightforward draw because they're
it's exceptional but I was the point I
was getting at earlier is they even for
someone like me who is a grandmaster
playing a position like this where only
my opponent has the activity and I'm
kind of stuck it's very difficult right
you you end up making more mistakes in
those situations where your best plan is
a shuffle back and forth because as
humans we want to do something active we
don't like you're sitting a home and
just like waiting to see something
happen most of us most of us yes yeah
car yakkin yakkin doing well here and
just say okay what is it why can well
that's why he's the Minister of Defence
though because those normal
psychological sort of just don't apply
to him I'm not convinced though right
how you decide my king from coming to f4
oh so the idea was that ninety six I
would have been able to finally trade
and then play king of four yeah White
was winning well actually you might be
able to do that but I was gonna say is
let's yeah I said I needed my king to
lose a temple but my king on a three
when your Knights already on e6 and then
I go king of four right it's like but
that was the night oh nice approach them
by karaoke because if what you say is
true that white was sort of totally in
the driver's seat to eventually find a
king journey that worked then black
needed to change the game a little bit
and so okay this looks bad right he's
given white the c6 pawn but maybe now he
has more dynamic joint chances since
he's sitting on the b4 pawn he blended
by allowing this knight to come to e5
Misha takes d4 I think he could have
just right that was much earlier in the
game but yeah yeah yeah and now he's now
he's suffering I I mean look at this two
one one on the right there c5 pawn is
purely passed if you take on g5 king g5
go king d4 okay I didn't even take he's
just saying okay your king is sit on it
sit tight and here comes white on King
to d4 even king c3 to guard the b4 pawn
and free up the c6 Knight to go to
somewhere like d4 and b5
Robert was doing a lot of teaching there
so didn't want to give a shout out there
were a number of people to subscribe
thank you for that and shout out to
kitty kitty his hiss who I think seems
to be the mystery behind all of these
subs and all of these all this love that
we're getting on twitch TV slash chess
so thank you kitty kitty hiss hiss and
all the support we're getting on the
twitch channel there I'm just I'm like
I'm shocked that Corey acting is just
blending away his positions because
right now he's dead lost or the F pawn
is rolling here comes King d4 or king of
three that's even better traps the King
on the H foil so that he can never even
get back
putting blackened and almost as eggs one
here Knight it's Jack at 506 f7 f8
probably good enough just do right away
obviously d3 can be met by King to e3
and the F phone oh no give King III then
then king g4 cuz f6 is met by 95 check
but no even at the end of that line if
black takes f6 c7 wins yeah hey Karl
calculated it faster than I could
highlight it
classic Hikaru calculating faster than
we can highlight on the board again
again now so it's check I wasn't sayin I
see a brilliant into that game there I
was saying after taking that forward and
c7 d2 you can't stop the promotion but
check comes first so yeah woo hey Carlo
Ricardo did a little he leaned back gave
a little scratch and peeked at the
camera so maybe that's a good clip if
everyone can help us share share some
fun clips that was that was a fun moment
there Ricardo converting and gaming back
to a two-game lead in the match he's
doing it for the fans clearly Caro does
it for the fans he really does I think
human magnets are both very aware of how
they
that on camera although we all miss a
nice giri who fell in West Feld a Wesley
so in the first round but that was that
was a fun one there yeah
okay what's going on here we're back to
karaoke and his white no more London
that means we're back to e4 or are we
know we got a weird one day I missed it
c4 we have an English for the first time
of the day and what is again we've seen
a lot of double pawns that's been a
theme of the day and but these double
pawns are good for white because they
open up the B file unless you you've
gotten rid of your beep on and already
what is black doing here like what's
your move because d4 is gonna be a big
threat for example if you you know if I
got another move d4 you can't take on d4
bishop h7 falls so this looks really not
good isn't bishop takes c6 a free pawn a
pawn is a pawn no matter where you live
Robert but also black can't even take on
d4 could still babies yeah well hey car
was shaking his head I think he also
knows that something went awry jokes
aside but yeah d5 is also something you
would consider okay you don't go for
material in a line like this but you
just have this sort of massive massive
advantage with those pawns grabbing all
all the squares big space advantage
right there so Sergei kind of taking his
time here to to choose his path to
victory or at least as far as the
opening is concerned yeah I think I
would be hesitant play d5 uses c5 then
is a target but I agree with you right
sometimes you don't want the material
you just want the position here is a
knock are y'all condition material world
he's a material girl in a material world
he wants to pawn he's a material
Princess Leia he's a material Princess
Leia and a material speech chess
championship so he wants the fun yeah
it's a clear pawn and now black steals
the same problems he did even what
materials even look at some point we'll
come to the B file and that's not gonna
be fun Knight g6 here can just get rid
of you you protect the knight attack the
bishop on f8 and you hit the rook on
yes nervous nobody's just getting a big
space advantage now I mean that's uh
he's gonna retreat the night back to f3
and black needs Bishop g4 to come in
quickly to try to undermine the palm but
he can't or I guess he can but Bishop
before you can take he ate and then c7
is falling in some lines so so he takes
on e1 first but but now White has time
to play even even rook d1 it can you
allow the double pawns yeah I mean
Queenie for he'd be taking up 3 I take
with the G pause it's not I thought rook
e1 might have been even better as a way
to do that cuz if Bishop a3 there was an
intermezzo like 26 check but okay ah
yeah you know that's it that's a fair
point shout-out to the last two subs
paying when GM and Gordon manly just
subscribe thank you for that okay all
right this isn't so easy Danny like you
want to go d5 of course but this pond c5
is hanging right every go Bishop e3
let's say at some point black and still
going f5 and trying to you know if I can
get f5f foreign in a timely manner then
that these F pawns here are also
permanently issues yeah I know I agree
it and it's it's still one that white
should be playing for two results here
but with a couple sets of double def
doubled pawns both F and C you're not in
the most not in the easiest position to
win when you're up upon right at some
point you may look for black or white to
play d5 anyway even with the c5 pawn
hanging and go for some sort of
aggressive counter play as the position
opens up right and now the King on g2
you know is actually kind of saved
because Queen HD would have loved to
have been played but the rook and Knight
was hanging I'm predicting at some point
here d5 is gonna come in a line like d5
Bishop c5 takes c6 Queen c6 rook da
check Bishop f8 do I not have Bishop d6
at the end of that line and in some
nasty no he does he doesn't go for it he
plays rookie e - I was I was just
fantasizing about this idea of getting
d5 and crushing on it so Queenie for
here and then there's f5 wow it was
funny of both players knew that
something had gone awry there
immediately black plays Queen of 7 hey
Carlos starts bobbing his head and
Sergei takes a deep breath of oh I
screwed this up yeah
I think he is I knew I was at weenie
four and just played Bishop you know
they keep the King stuck but for f5 now
the king can go to age seven
not to mention queen g6 check and you
might have some difficulty with your own
King for white so huge oversight and now
after he betrayed Queens and blacks is
better yeah black is the only one who
can win now because these D pawns the a
pawn these are much easier targets for
black than anything White House yeah so
this is the right idea obviously white
is threatening Bishop b6 here everybody
and the bishop on f8 is the problem for
black so hit Carla's got to find some
way to solve that Bishop e6 is still a
threat maybe just King h7 now probably
that was the point about five was to get
the Queen off of e4 well rook takes deep
No yeah it takes d4 Bishop d6 maybe and
now doesn't try to take it ago Queen g6
check and take on d6 I use how many I
yeah I don't know if it's enough phones
but it is sneaky above you Oh actually
after roof d4 Bishop e6 Queen g6 check
yeah you go into rook t1 check aha he is
going for that you're right head up to
the host of bonk ooh Bam Bam quail who
was the ghost of Banquo who just
subscribed the King h3 is the only move
because every if you open to the
background rook do you want check wins
for black you go up with material and
now I think it's a perpetual wow what a
hilarious repetition yeah not that not
the normal way you reach a trough but a
card Obama has said he's happy with the
draw at this point maintaining a
two-game lead again is kind of all he
can ask for with only 12 minutes a
little more than 12 minutes before we
head into the bullet portion Robert the
this could be the I guess second to last
game likely we have two more
three-minute games before we get into
the fastest portion of the day yeah what
what a weird game I mean crank was up a
pawn a free pawn I move like 12 or
whatever and then all of a sudden it's
like you know he's had opportunities we
just convert so no he really has it's
it's been it's been strange I think that
part of it has to go to hey Karl you
notice he we haven't highlighted but
he's up on time a lot and in the
three-minute portion it's been a key
thing because maybe maybe Sergei trying
to play faster to make sure he
not down one time Robert is leading him
as you said maybe he played too fast in
some positions kind of letting his
advantages slip
yeah and that last game car knockin
really blitz out the opening had a great
position he played more mainline stuff
so I think that's should be kuryakin's
plan going forward just why not answer
the things that he feels comfortable
with and yeah you've got
I know London every game wish yeah maybe
he does feel comfortable in it but it's
not as something's gone wrong here for
for his Sergei given the positions he's
been getting out of the B three lines
this is now a position where you really
really like White's plan everybody this
is a this is what we call a pan off
structure if you split the board White
has three pawns versus blacks two pawns
and that that basically gives black a
three a white a three-on-two advantage
because unless black can mobilize a five
which right now White has put the full
clamps on that breakthrough black will
never be able to realize the counterpart
advantage which is the five on on four
on the kingside so something went wrong
here in the opening for Sergei this is
this is this is a pretty nice positional
edge for white white can just play h3
here yeah Sergei I can't replace it
before I can say it and I don't even
know if this is too much to say but I
would not be surprised this is already
like winning four-way yeah I know it
seriously and that is definitely how we
think about this positionally everybody
regardless of what the engines say
grandmasters I'm not one but I play one
on chefs TV sometimes look at this
position and just already feel like
white is just crushing because of this
positional advantage that we're
highlighting and look at her Carla's
play so just imagine everybody's flip
the board and look at the fact that
white is basically just up a pawn over
here and black is good right now doing
everything he can to mobilize some sort
of dynamic transition you got to try to
change the structure but but acardo's
not gonna let it happen g4 what a nice
move by the way denying the knight DF v
squared like that
yeah just made sure that dark square
bishop has nowhere to go
denying the f5 square the Fein keto
knight on g7 looks like a donkey you
still can't get out against donkeys um
well Danny the donkey right yeah what do
you have abouts Danny the donkey just
you whoa 85 apparently you and Magnus
have nothing against Danny the donkey so
85 the point was that Queen takes a five
rook a one took a seven so that
like I let me let me highlight that
sassiness on the analysis for Queen
chicks a5 rook a 1 and then rook takes a
7 that's how you aggressively advance
your three onto majority everybody take
notes I don't think I mean you have to
go c6 here right because otherwise
Knight b8 come to c6
yeah you can't allow black to blockade
because now the structure the 3 on 2 is
frozen and the d4 pawn becomes the
biggest weakness on the board so Vacarro
has to dynamically justify what he's
done oh he doesn't
I think c6 had to be played there yeah
that's strange
well I guess he 5 was it was a move was
Knight takes e5 a move with the b2
bishop and maybe not I don't know what
I'm saying all right definitely Oh 95
Queen 60 F 4 GF 4 g5 and I hit your
bishop yeah but Sergei has done what he
does best he's wiggled and maneuvered
his way out of a clearly worst position
and Hikaru not bobbing his head anymore
I'll tell you that and lots of questions
in the chat about what it car was
listening to we already told you in the
last match he confirmed he was listening
to the offspring
I know let that sink in for a second
kind of weird but yeah apparently so
he's not bobbing his head anymore
something went awry here even though all
of our positional assessments of how
much better white was we were right but
Hikaru I think missed a big chance when
he didn't play c6 I think Sergei missed
a chance to instead of taking on e3 I
thought he showed a five and after D 65
Bishop e7 followed up with 96 piled
pressure in the c5 pawn again quantity
of pawns are not important in this
endgame I mean they are obviously often
but at that particular moment that extra
e pawn wasn't going anywhere because the
knight was coming to e6 and we were
hitting c5 so I think a missed
opportunity there by Sir getting some
really active counter plan but perhaps
even seize the advantage but now the
question is can it karo actually do
anything right surrogates plan is very
simple king f7 maybe rook e8 bishop f8
don't move like that it sounds
ridiculous but like that's kind of what
he's trying to do is like just stabilize
and then you know say what are you doing
and yeah maybe I mean he's really done a
good job maneuvering his way out of that
position and he made maybe he will
eventually get e5 still hasn't gotten
that break that we've been saying black
needs in this structure for awhile but
but again white spawns are frozen so you
just you feel much better about blacks
chances are you saying that he should
let it go make like Elsa that's right
yeah but okay so black can't do anything
and a big problem for black if you can't
rewrite this Knight to c6
then I was in c6 and you can go rook e8
and whatever I say okay this game should
just fizzles out instantly the problem
is the knight cannot there's no way to
get it to lay on g7 is terrible trapped
right it has p8 and g7 s is only two
squares which leads me to believe that
white can go Knight d2 it's B 1 C 3 a
tube before at some point I don't know
in what order you can go through g1 I
mean will you get the point the
essential thing at night on g7 has its
two squares it can only go back and
forth but then the thing is even if you
get night before and you take on c6 and
let those rook takes c6 can white make
progress there I think the answer is yes
because you're gonna some people rook h1
in pawn h4 and open up that file but hey
car is taking his sweet time it brings
King to d3 maybe and you know maybe if
the knight moves in Yui 5 is that the
fear that can't be scary but no it's got
to be part of what he's worried about
but as you said I think he's
highlighting that he's in control here
Hikaru is sort of despite having miss
played the position he's still the only
one who can decide whether a 5 will give
authority over their taking or taketh
away
and who is Bishop takes g5 and
ninety-five checks okay not yet but I'm
looking at some sort of chats go shot
white might try to come up with right
and I wouldn't take on g5 why is that
night not going to be for let's say 91e
591 'if I've oh I want one thing to
highlight it's possible that even if you
get the knight to be four you're not
threatening to take on c6 because the
rook can just take back and you have no
ways to break through still but I was
thinking about that but then at some
point after I do that like I can just
essentially have the same position up in
exchange and then go like King G move my
king go rook h1 pawn h4 right something
like okay whoa even that's possible
there may not be enough but yeah
alright so eventually black says I'm not
gonna sit tight now did cardiac and do
that because he had 30 seconds on the
clock and didn't want to continue to be
grounded down grinded ground grain did
you get it
but or or is this the right thing for
black to do shout out to our last sub I
think it was Steve is 2 or something
thanks for subbing on Twitch thanks for
all the support everybody I think black
is fine here bishop things before FG 7
King g7 i-85 isn't yeah so do you live
is falling it's a bishop AIF
oh ma you're right yeah I don't know
this is harder for black to defend with
with no time on the clock I think then
not realize 55 in rook d7 is coming that
g7 pawn is uh is either really dangerous
or possibly poison a rook d7 Intermezzo
gobbled with the rook and here white is
in complete control
well how do you make progress don't ask
me how do I make progress I'm not here
to make progress no I actually I agree
that white is looking very good here but
at some point what are you doing right a
5 a 4 a 3 a 2 is a looks like pretty
legitimate threat
yeah the Brooklyn behind the a pawn is
certainly alright a move Kevin freezes
white out that is so brilliant everybody
and threatens rook a eight fall about
rook takes g7 if Sergei wins this game
with black down on time this would be a
huge victory to bring things close
before they head into bullet I wouldn't
idea I think that white should have just
promoted their giving up and just taking
over the seventh rank and gonna cook e5
to e7 and there's made a draw yeah a
great claim but now okay there's no way
that black is that you know winning here
anything but that was just fascinating
yep
shoutout to Jess underscore am thank you
for subbing on Twitch oh okay rook g6
alright no your king g1 I guess but okay
car was trying to win on time is this
yeah that's not not a not a novelty idea
for her car to try to win on time so the
difference about these SCC's
the increment leads to a little bit less
flagging somebody because you're faster
with the mouse a little more having to
play accurate moves but but this is
probably just gonna be a draw here with
neither side really pushing because
they'll mate their own king okay maybe
I'm wrong maybe I'm wrong okay
be a draw you can't just be a draw
though because there's no way that white
can do anything but check here without
blacks rooks flipping them flipping
behind the pawns and and if you leave
with your work down with a meeting but
check then black just perpetual checks
you for from now until Kingdom Come so
this is should be a job everybody
barring some awesome train wreck under
time pressure so let's all be on the
edge of our seat that was this out you
know got heated very quickly here that
can't seven I was really fascinating and
I thought that you know to avoid being
worse perhaps you know a car should have
sacrificed that pawn is taking over the
seventh rankings middle repetition but
this this will do thanks for subscribing
Joe well I wonder how aware a carro is
of the game clogged I think he just
knows he's got to take a draw and he
does so by repetition so likely this
next game that's starting barring any
massive blunders or something else weird
will be the last classical three-minute
game everybody don't go anywhere we're
gonna see chess960 and in a match like
this which is only separated by a single
game although I know I guess it's two
games right now for tomorrow but every
single game at this point matters car
honking has to keep it close and impress
us in bullet if he's gonna pull the pull
the victory what's going on with
kayaking right now he's spending twenty
thirty seconds on the second move you
must have a lag or something I'm not
sure what's is just me as he not made a
second move
am i havnt have a lag honestly yeah cuz
now he's moving so that's weird
alright well we've seen this one before
and last time Sergey had pretty much you
know close to winning position and move
whatever it was 12 and this idea of
Bishop d3 to e2 is very interesting and
the idea is just to get this night off
the board and use this Bishop on f3
which is on the you know the long
diagonal and the black Bishop on c8 is
clearly worse than its counterpart so
all things considered I mean these
openings are great for white
yep you over but he was he hasn't been
able to convert as well as he is he'd
like to last game as you said he was up
a clear pawn but a peaceful result
nonetheless so I don't make this
decision by crack instead of g3 why not
go Bishop a3 first and then g3 and then
the pieces on the board yeah I mean
thing is your bishop is better on this
diagonal then blacks is gonna be just
sitting on h6 it's just I don't know
it's okay black white is something very
well here look at this backward beep all
right c5 yeah yeah this isn't one of
those positions Danny you've seen a
classical game and you're just like oh
you know that black is gonna get ground
right down no you're opening some book
like this is like Karpov rib lead
1970-something right and you just know
that whites just gonna grind black down
and how many times was Ridley grinded by
Karpov I need the PG kind I have no idea
but it was it got ugly there for a while
alright well that's the end of our three
to portion regardless of whether a grind
takes place here or not hey Carl will
likely be taking a two-game lead because
I don't know that white can lose this
especially with c6 falling here so
although look at that if c6 falls Bishop
a six and then the f1 rook is
overwhelmed do the f2 pawned defense
everybody but you see four there right
so you can you gotta yeah yeah so why
again I think the core should not lose
this we know here car is black oh I'm
sorry I'm I'm confusing confusing my
colors my fault oh yes no guys a weird I
don't get that why not just Queen takes
c6 he must have missed c4 after after
Bishop
six I think what unlikely right was it
rook c8 after that maybe after Seif I
don't know what it was but okay well I
said right okay Queen f5 so rook b1
right to go to b8 rook b12 b8 one of my
favorite maneuvers yeah why does my
seeing me okay yeah we might yeah maybe
even better and in fact how do you got
to go back to f6 I think with the Queen
well no but now I can take on c5 if you
erupted d8 I take on d8 take you have
Queen of fate at the ot1 now that does
not look good
that that looks not favorable so that
Queen c5 might backfire as well well
then you look it at the end there maybe
no it looks those highly sister Stacey
say it seems it seems like white is a
blunder away from winning this game
black is really coming under fire here
oh if I was a creative way to deal with
the Bishop problem unleashing the Queen
to defended everybody Bishop here right
before oh no boys on business before I
think you missed that if it takes
everybody Roberts ideas you trade a fate
take c8 with check and then the rook
Hanes in the end yeah and if you after
mission before here Queenie six I just
go right back to d6 probably anis yeah
no I already bishop before look nasty
but it still looks amazing right you're
you're AB upon it's a past see pawn
yeah he's gonna bring the rook should be
one and try to come into b7 the C pawn
should be enough to to push yeah this is
a position where White has many chances
even if you're not up a pawn but now
that you are that doubled C pawned the
fact that they're both pass really helps
black has to come up with a quick
decision of where are my best drawing
chances here do I play King of six and
Bishop e6 do I try to just play Bishop
c6 but I can't really hold the blockade
because rook b1 rook b6 is coming okay
Brooke a5 but that allows c6 so let's
see what he calculated interesting
that's a nice idea Robert he's gonna put
this work on c5 sort of you know swedge
himself in between
to past see pollens nice idea right now
Vigo Bishop e6 pawn t6 rook d1 yep rook
five roof d7 check and then put my pawn
c7 right so you make c4 though okay I'm
happy to give that one up I'm just
wondering if that's enough I just don't
think it is because the black king is so
close so you have efore king e5 King D
six and it's just not not in time but
the thing is if you run your King over
right there your g6 pawn would be a weak
as well yeah yeah no I mean eventually Y
could try to win with that decoy idea of
Robert has everybody which is okay give
up everything here as long as the Brooks
are traded and then white wins the key
component okay I guess he's saying if
you take on c6 ago rook age four but why
would you give up oh I guess if c7 you
go h5 and then yeah and then black could
I mean okay like black and everyone but
that that would have been a weird
turnaround where suddenly white is white
is not happy but you hadn't give a karo
credit here I mean I feel like he's
again maneuvered himself out of that
terrible position and I don't see black
losing this endgame
so King f3 I mean I think is not in this
end game giving up the f2 part is not
advisable but it might not also be the
end of the world and here you guys g4
check ok h4 good start
yeah this is I I feel like white has
very very good winning chances here
because even if I have to use my pawn as
a decoy I like pushing the h-bond I
start gobbling up the e pawns I'm on my
kinking I like the og 5 yeah King III 2
e 2 d 3 now Oh actually cuz the Brooke
is the rook is defending h4 there should
be some way now for oh wait no I guess
the F pawn would fall yeah you want to
go King b6 somebody wanted h5 I don't
think it's timed right right now right
h5 sacrifice for the cheap pawn to
become everything the body needs go get
a queen but huh maybe something went
wrong oh yeah
so have you take enough for anytime
you're trading off your opponent's
double pawn it feels like maybe you
missed something and with Hikaru's king
getting so active here is he just gonna
play tickle tickle tickle
yep king d3 i don't know i mean you even
keep the rook behind the palm down
rookie to to c2 is gonna be quite a
nuisance the car was quickly calculating
rook D - I can see it in his eyes but it
doesn't work because h5 okay but if he
plays rook h2 or rook a - I think the
black is still doing just fine and now
there's threats of check so got to be
careful c5
oh wait and see if I there's a hang yes
c5 rook a3 was winning I'm blender
sometimes you know a sharp human you're
you are human and that's okay okay but a
car was is holding again and and again
very patiently keeping his king is the
more active one of the two rookie three
check comes in i think now brook h3 will
be played yeah don't even bother giving
up the e6 pawn i think black is black is
gonna hold the draw
yeah after rook age four you have to go
king d3 and then just rotate through
check the king can infiltrate yeah black
and choose here King d4 or look behind
the pawn and if c5 king d5 and we're
just gonna have a draw as everybody gets
traded although if you're King before
here g6 is gonna be a problem
came before g6 okay I could probably mow
but wait what's happening here the two
pawns are getting going yeah a car was
also waiting on his chair what he's
definitely doing a head shake it must
happen something must've something weird
happened here I mean losing I think he's
lost well I was gonna say what is e five
possible and then King Kong
oh no cuz c6 can you see they was it was
too late yeah you this you know what
this is Robert this is a puzzle book can
somebody clip this moment I want to make
a video look at that this is the king is
actually cut outside the box because of
the pawn on e6 and all of those and all
of those positions the white pawn was
advancing and the King was sort of cut
off by his own pawn couldn't get back to
stop it and here now g7 are
he ate or something you know all these
movies are winning yeah because why can
transition into a lucena yep easy Brooke
ending wind where's my twitch friend
kappa blanka yeah where'd he go
couples lot of fan is going nuts he's
about to come out of his chair here in
the in the yet some in sloth fan is is
loving himself a good end game but okay
no this was this was really really a
huge huge game okay Carl can winning
this game cutting it to a single game
lead with a chance to tie but Danny
winning well he he's blender away the
win did he blow it om yeah yeah y'all
get winning this game as well oh and he
any any and he's leaning back and
frustrated what happened there cardiac
conduction or you're just thrilled about
the fact that you maintain your two-game
lead and and move into chess960 wowzers
that was not good yeah all of a sudden
you were chatting and I was looking at
like waste like I don't think this is a
winning anymore cuz the pawn got to e3
which never should happen he should have
went east seven earlier and then g7 the
rook to e8 and just Lucena but ya know
g7 rookie it was too loose II know we
were talking about and he he didn't
transition into it alright so now we
have a 960 we're weirdly there are lots
of bishops in the B file and lots of
bishops on the B file yeah this is a
Samoan y can move the bishop everybody
and then try to castle long drop the
King on a1 quickly getting the D file
that would be what I would be tempted to
do even even Bishop a5 I would I would
consider alternatively you can go Queen
H a torque wrench one and counsel
Kingston rightfully Queen you're
trapping your Queen on h1 to castle
might not be advised ok 904 is
interesting probably forces f3 yep he
plays it and not bad for white though I
can get e4 still try to maneuver and get
get some coordination where that D file
you like
reason where I'm highlighting everybody
is now that the structure has changed
where white has the C pawn black has the
D pawn the open files sort of create a
situation where casting long is just
immediately dangerous for black and
white can pull it off yeah and where's
this night going from f-4e six but do
you really want to allow fairly yes I
was thinking instead of taking these six
used on e4 right away and just taking
more space cuz now White has an idea of
Bishop d4 a4 a5 like very thematic you
see in Hedgehog type positions right
worst version than a hedgehog because
your your I know after you still can't
Castle King said I was compared to say
yeah I was gonna say you actually you
get a black and white can both still
Castle to either side everybody okay
Kokoro place for a5 what's he calculated
here Ike he's got he's got a look number
is that number five he's got a car look
number five they're the kind of
puppy-dog eyebrows they're that means he
really is confident he should be caught
me so much space he's got you know
uncompromised pawn structure a ton of
space g4 will kick that night back to g7
again yeah any castles King side
interesting okay well yeah I like this
for white look at that if he gets rid of
the light square bishop he might be in a
position just run the a pawn here
karyakin is sort of shuffling in his
chair
a4 a5 is potentially on the way
yes c5 is also on the agenda White's
attack is coming much faster than blacks
here yeah Knight f4 it seems like it's
you got to play it right you're just
gonna deny on h5n2 me anything
okay takes there but here comes here
comes a 45 maybe I mean there's also 94
Knight d5 but you don't want to give up
the F for square okay so so yeah a 45
back to that I guess a5 their response
to be always Bishop takes if I a b6
Bishop e6 with check so you make it a
one move there if I geez I was gonna say
you have to worry about a5 a6 and I
might be Bob's your uncle on b7 there mu
he takes it
that is a positional concession why
don't you go queen g6 there and I don't
agree with you I think he needed to play
queen g6 which wasn't time to stuff
don't like squirt meeting idea
okay queen g6 runs right into queen e3
probably but queen e3 is not that scary
right because your queen d3 there so
queen g6 is the move now because queen
e3 queen d3 you take on a 7-inch go king
b7 you've taken my extra pawn right
that's an unimportant yeah so
unlikely calculated exactly that he's
going for it here he comes
yeah and I think me worse is behind him
because yeah that was a nice maneuver so
B takes a 5 that we initially were sort
of shocked out turns out to be the right
positional approach for black right to
make sure that no no attacking chances
continued there is black somehow better
DTR like going deep now Ruby 8 maybe
king c6
yeah blacks I'm better but blacks I
would not think black is worse no you're
right the King on c6 guards its weakness
on d7 he already plays for p8 he's
preparing to gang up on the b3 pawn
everybody and the 5 is not a my pawn is
overextended look out for Brooke f5 i I
agree and and still if if this ends up
being a win although we've already had
winning positions for Sergei that he
didn't convert on you start to wonder
you know how did he not how did he not
convert on that last winning rook ending
right because this match could be almost
tied right now and he's instead he could
be down a couple games headed into
bullets there's d6 coming at some point
it has to right d6 that way I take with
a bishop on e6 yeah he does it he likes
it why is he offering a draw is Sergei
offering a draw like there's no you
don't save time by making a draw here
yeah I don't know well I mean from a
match strategy perspective maybe he
forgets that the clock isn't actually
running during the chess960 but I'm
surprised by that as well you you have
to try to fight your way back in here if
your Sergei write down two games and
it's one of those end games where you
know black can go a4 at the right moment
perhaps you can start making progress on
you know the pawns get separated so you
can even make some progress there's an
a4 now
yeah you got a partly because Bishop E
ones a threat oh did he miss fish
everyone why would you start with rookie
I'm so confused I'm confused draw or
take a breath it's okay Robert although
not your fault but again black is I mean
black zoom has to be doing quite
decently here I would say anywhere
people doing fine but again he's also
got 30 seconds to at carlo's two minutes
yeah thank you tella tell it'll um be I
always wanted to say Teletubbies
whatever happened did the Teletubbies
anyway thanks for the sub tell us alum B
you watch Teletubbies as a kid admit it
I actually didn't good for you
thank you I guess okay with the game not
f4 so II for why do you eat for is it up
it's a passed pawn
I don't know Robert stop yelling at me
okay yeah it was good
didn't even win the b3 pawn actually
yeah well circuits down on time and
clearly he's nervous about that sort of
situation where he's under that pressure
and I think that's that's easy thing to
do psychologically and hey Carlos draw
and at this time your Sergei just
immediately agrees to it so missing your
Lord of the time travel Danny I
understand go 8-4 he's worried about
competing pass pawns
yes let's analyze that for a second I'll
back up real quick and show everybody
here on the on the main board why uh
what would have happened perhaps on e4
so f4 e for what are you saying I'm
saying that how you gonna protect b3
isn't he if we're just winning on the
spot looks good I'll say that looks good
III yeah I mean okay so if work to c3
Bishop D for the rook has to leave the
the third rank and and with it the d3
pawn fall so I agree and something about
the way that these critical moments are
breaking down is the players get under
time pressure just tells me that Sergei
is just that much that much more nervous
playing against Hikaru right with with
with very limited time on the clock as
some of his decisions are not as good as
that
we've seen cardiac and playing in two
previous two matches but other than that
Robert I don't really have an excuse or
or an explanation for why Sergei didn't
play I mean seriously this is two moves
away before they agree to withdraw
efore is winning and he just missed it
and you're Meyers in the chat
Grandmaster York Meyer who we all know
and love
I said Sergey missing his chances like I
did against him which I about compare
those situations but well George Org
actually had had a tough matchup playing
Sergei and round one but ya know Sergei
is definitely missing his chances and
the players are taking their their last
break Robert let's remind everybody why
why and and who we are here this is the
speech s championship khari Aachen vs.
Nakamura only 30 minutes left until this
match is over and in the books it's a
two-game lead so yes all the stats
coming in tell us that well the the
bullet portion is going to be favoring
Hikaru Nakamura and that's kind of why
you see this sort of match trajectory
starting at 5050 leading toward karak
and kind of going down in the green and
Nakamura trending upwards as we expect
given their ratings coming in given
their previous performance and how we
kind of put that together this is really
getting closer and closer to being a
match that Nakamura is gonna put away so
will will Sergei surprise us here Robert
in the next 30 minutes basically what
we've seen thus far no because when
surrogates in time trouble he clearly
you seem getting much much worse right
whereas I feel
Cara's in time trouble he's very
resourceful you don't see him really
blundering to the same degree yellow him
during this game you an f4 but he did
that because he knew cardiac was in time
trouble so I think he just hit car was a
quick maneuver that's tied up I think
I'll put it he he knows where his pieces
belong he does instantaneously and he's
a lot of experience on the site with the
bullet chess and I don't know Sergei is
a pedigree and bullet everyone's seen
him in the masters he's played this far
he looked good against nip oh he looked
good against Meyer
but again that's two matches and I've
seen a car play for years you know well
we're gonna find out whether Sergei has
enough in the tank to defy the odds and
beat her car and I'll come more in
bullet right now but
the last portion is underway and we have
30 minutes on the clock with ooh
okay this is I've played it so many
times in bullet chess the point is it's
a not really a French it's kind of you
know starts to e46 but you just think
have bishop attack the center yep and
white is always better here like without
fail yeah no it's a it's a it's a weird
weapon that Hikaru also you say you
played a lot in bullet a car Oh probably
plays it in bullet as much as anybody
and tries to get these weird positions
but I don't know that I agree with you I
don't know that he can play these kind
of dubious openings against Sergey and
and not get in trouble in bullet but it
hasn't stopped him from changing from b3
although we already see black kind of
jumping out to a bit of a very easy and
comfortable position here yeah at the
time it's very important surgeries I'm
doing badly on the clock he's got over
50 seconds and you know playing well but
you can't move this slowly and not get
enough of an initiative in the position
because that's what a car a car all a
car needs is equality yep he doesn't
need better he no Knight was quite easy
he can be slightly worse yeah but that
that c5 move was was taking advantage of
the temporary pin that was there on the
default everybody was kind of well-timed
like a carro but now you've got white
with a three-on-two in the end game so
uh with that I was considered the
opposite of well-timed
I mean it was well time since there's a
pin but the downside is yes you often
want to make this break
look how cleanly White's pieces start
yeah in bit whereas Knight come to c6
you can go b4 b5 who is a mission
painting on e7 just okay white is white
is totally in the driver's seat here yup
and even c5 is a threat because if you
take with the poncey finite 67 for
Bishop takes e5 wins in exchange so not
looking good for Hikaru
yeah and together this is this is the
kind of mission
yep there is game just on the spot these
are the these are the kind of things
that Hikaru can do a lot in bullet
against most the people he plays and and
he also does it in sudden-death kind of
stuff so I think sometimes those initial
transition say Carl forgets that one
you're playing card yakin you're playing
Carlsen you're playing better players
and two we
the increment you've really expect
Kuryakin to be able to win this game
because he's up he's up a full exchange
it shouldn't be a problem
yeah well though look at the clock
situation 19 seconds left there you know
blenders definitely can happen but I
mean the position now is actually quite
complicated now night g3 at night g3
comes in and oh queen e5 is a shot there
and white is still actually winning at
the endgame
oh here Queen f3 takes gf3 yeah yeah
okay so white still has the advantage
with the rook eventually coming into d7
here everybody just too much although
rookie in a6 right you're not uh
you're not really in time there yeah not
my side can you trade on d8 no yeah I
guess he does he he could take the C
pawn yeah then and then play Knight b7 I
think an a5 something like that might be
Sam Bishop before the on your nice
strapped and you're not okay this this
is my dear just your the right idea for
sure just getting this beep on but there
may not be enough with your double deaf
pawns it's not exactly an ideal
structure over there alright so here
comes back to King d5 I mean this is
turning around a logic are Nakamura
style and uh oh there's a pawn yeah car
might get away with this one
Hey sorry I just he's moving kind of
slowly right look at the twenty second
time advantage yeah it's such a good
position and he like not only was he not
move it quickly is making the wrong
moves and that's just you know a
disastrous combination so again
important to note H pawn is not matching
the bishop color so all white needs to
do is sacrifice the D pawn all right now
you just take this on
somehow white sacrifice is the night for
the G pawn in any fashion and it's a
draw but Hikaru might try to make that
as tricky as possible especially with
Sergei only having three seconds on the
clock okay this should also be good
enough for a draw because the King is
active enough that once this Knight gets
back should be a draw so okay you're
come here comes the the night and with
it 92 or 95 check both work and the game
is drawn well okay 25 minutes left now
Sergei
still down by two games Robert you're in
sir gays corner you're his coach despite
everything that's happened so far you
have a chance to win this match what do
you tell him oh he's doing it right
exactly correct right now speed up and
he's playing very quickly in this
opening and you know he shouldn't be
companies getting good positions he just
needs to maintain his time on the clock
so he's not at a huge disadvantage and
this is perfect right now
he's over a minute he's equal on the
clock and again this Bishop on g2 facing
a brick wall on the diagonal so efore
well time yeah that was nice because now
the transition is this is a little
better for a car than the last time we
saw the structure where the center
remained closed and black held that deep
my point
okay now why it's getting d5 himself
right so this is business this is
awesome for white yep so as soon as I
was talking how he's playing well he
then makes an error and now he's just
like lost so that's fun I just
things aren't clicking for Sergey right
now and he's probably frustrated a car
is definitely happy and quick d4 looks
nice by the way yeah everything's frozen
right Quinn d4 was that a was that an
Elsa reference number two it wasn't
meant to be one but I guess it did
become one I'm not sure why her car
didn't play 24 but decides that gobbling
the g5 pawn is enough to make him happy
all right well you know the rook comes
to the D file the b7 pawn is still under
fire under gaze of the bishop on g2 this
just looks like a pretty simple
conversion for white yeah and with a car
with the white pieces I feel confident
he'll win
he still has to be careful because he's
exposed as King a lot of yep what
recently done with g4 to G fine I don't
like that push right if there's some way
that black gets things like Queen d2
Knight f4 and the Queen and Knight start
to work together that could be the one
way that Sergei kind of flips flips this
thing around
yeah 9 to 4 yeah 94 coming now and Queen
Dido no not going to to the Brooks
hanging death but but yes here here
comes here comes trickiness actually
it's very difficult for white to make
progress because again bishops only
occupy
one diagonal so yeah you're really
looking if that rook comes a d6 to d4
and then if that move also just takes
the rook away from the attack so that
moves like Queen d2 Queen d4 activity
with the Queen followed by things like
90 to check and you just start to feel
like there's some real chances here yeah
rook d6 here exactly
rook d6 rook d4 okay gobbles to g5 pawn
with check also also a good idea and
look at the King safety blacks King is
much safer than whites
okay White's isn't in that bad shape but
the point is that blacks ting is very
safe you only have one extra pawn it's
not a clear pass pawn over there on the
Queen side and you have rook h5 here for
example okay rook c5 just be active be
quick yeah the time solution is not good
for Sergei that's for sure shout out to
Montclair Sopranos who just who just
subscribed likely the courtesy of Kitty
hiss hiss I don't know but thanks to all
the support and everybody who's who's
been watching the show if you've been
here from the beginning Corey Hawkins
gonna get this win if he does it'll be
down to a single game so we still have a
match and we still have a chance for for
the person currently trailing down by
two games yeah I don't think he's
getting this one though he's down he's
down upon although now he's not down
pawn
that's a rook ofor but it settles on the
draw and takes his chances in the next
game looks like that's what he's gonna
do well okay
Sergei is is again like he's partly he's
happy with the draw but partly he has to
make his move here at some point and
since those of you who've been with us
know that he's mischances had a couple
games that he really should have won you
start to wonder if the writing's on the
wall he's got to get some victories here
well the car has to stop playing this
opening he's gotten a lot of bad
positions from it and okay he changed it
up this time to go on v6 and being keto
early and taking on f3 yeah and you know
White has the two bishops more space so
that's all good and fun Bishop b4 is
always an option you know you can
consider going d5 at some point for a
white as well but black is quite solid
let's let's start there
that being said two bishops and open
space are nice but look at the pawn
structure really ugly from whites point
of view CC pawns double isolated F pawns
or H pawn is isolated you're a pawn is
isolated if black is time with a Knight
a5 and just close off the Queen side so
yeah I think the car is done well here
in itial II I thought he shouldn't enter
this opening again now that the game's
progressed I'm you know I think that
blacks turn okay yeah and white is
positionally works with the pawns a
whole bunch of doubled and some isolated
pawns to Fischer wouldn't be proud
the okay black black is gonna hold all
the cards as far as the breakthroughs go
a six b5 if he wants maybe f6e five so
yeah this this approach by Hikaru fee
and ket owing and taking up three
earlier is definitely better against
this this English opening that Sergei
has been employing the problem is from
Hikaru's perspective he's trying to win
he needs to get a rook to the fifth rank
so I can go to h5 and f5 and things like
that
but there are no open files for his
rooks to work okay so if he goes b5
everything gets traded there that should
fizzle out lowest heel out eighty-five
bringing the king over to the King side
Wow allowing 85 was a Blosser everybody
because sweeping a5 would allow c5
winning a piece didn't c5 one piece
anyway instead of a five to the analysis
board Dave was it really yeah I guess he
there was a pawn of c7 the bishop was
trapped and he missed a free okay he's
winning anyway alright I don't want say
winning anyone stopping yes c5 was just
with him oh my god this is over he gave
the answer was solved so the expert of
chess 2017 thank you for subscribing Wow
okay well okay karaoke is going to win
this game assuming he can handle his
time pressure he six just do DS yes
thank you yeah you're right now he needs
to speed up he's he's playing he's
taking his time on moves and again I I
have a theory he's a little more
intimidated under time pressure than he
needs to be won by resignation yep no
song via meant thank you for subscribing
by the way Jenny would I say about
cracking maybe we're under estimating
him the bullet he's plus one in the
bullet thus far so all right well we
underestimated Nakamura in the blitz so
that if the table would turn that would
certainly be poetic justice
hey Caro actually did better in the
Blitz than Sergei and currently Sergei
up up a game and bullet but but okay
Hikaru at some point has to get away
from the dubious positions he's been
giving himself pretty much from the
start so okay so here he's something
I'll say that I think is important to
this match and I think hey car feels
more comfortable in random positions I
think Sergei needs to be in his in his
element in things he's seen before in
his preparation I mean this prep
okay Queen h5 here is just good for
black by the way okay he missed it but
queen h5 that is just you're pinning the
rook h2 is in there attack like just
slightly better position anyway but the
car can play random positions very very
well and that's not to say that sorry it
can't it just feels like Hikaru doesn't
get as nervous he just you know he feels
at home anywhere although right now
Bishop takes g3 I don't know if he's
feeling at home there and you see a car
offer to draw again and Sergei decline
the draw this has just been a an
interesting match approach where I you
know Sergei missing some opportunities
and blitz at Carl may be performing I
think he outplayed Sergei for the
majority of the blitz but now rook up
three look at Sergei up on time and
bullet plants the brook on f3 if he goes
on to win this game and ties it and
bullet we are we are literally on the
verge of the first the first bullet
nobody has ever beaten Hikaru in the
bullet portions of any match including
Magnus Carlsen who beat Nick ro but
didn't win the bullet it karo won the
bullet by a game or two
alright and watch out because now all of
a sudden there's big trouble for a car a
because when H for their queen is to be
attacked thing
this is e5 this is ugly well if a car
thought it was gonna be lights out as
long as he could make it to the bullet
win this situation he is he's gonna be
proven wrong you could want Queen B 1
there I mean so many things look so
amazing I'm not sure like it's just
winning partners t1 Queen e1 set
well King e1 allows Bishop before this
lost bishop h2 ok mission to was
winning on the spot
Sergei missing
but Hikaru still knows he's busted okay
so excuse me that's plus two for Sergei
Kardashian be three and oh one thank you
for the subscription call your friends
everybody we could be we I think I was
about to take the tone that the writing
was on the wall with a car Oh having to
lead in bullet but with 15 minutes left
the match is tied and it just goes to
show that we don't have enough
information on cardiac in to really you
know we know over the board how good it
is we haven't see him enough and we want
to see him every time playing on chess
calm but he's clearly a force in these
bullet chess right yeah absolutely well
he is the reigning world blitz champion
remember everybody we've talked about
that and he's uh not somebody you think
of in terms of online household names
with Hikaru and Magnus but but okay we
will see see if a car pulls it together
and the bullet or if Sergei completes an
epic comeback and I think hit card needs
to kind of calm down and stop maybe
playing these like really random
openings that are kind of dubious and
that last game is not what I'm talking
about wishin generally was east six
basic stuff that he played earlier this
is a perfectly normal position that I
would see these top players playing a
classical game but he can't just rely on
his you know kind of instinct and just
kind of his his town that we all know
because reputation is one thing proving
it is another and cardiac it's not gonna
be scared and he's he's showing a really
good fight right now now nice c4 I mean
you're not nice well I think I think
well you said it sure I think that car
was probably got in the best position
he's had out of the opening in any of
the bullet games so far and and we'll
see if he goes back to b3 or if he uses
this as a sign that he also needs to
play something a little more mainline as
white but okay what black is black is
doing just fine here that's better
I mean I like black Allison big che
phase maquette mix shapes
thanks for surviving okay I mean why
it's pretty solid
oh did you six Bishop takes age three
was a threat King h1 stopped at Queen h4
maybe Bishop h3 comes back okay that's a
nice move h5 everybody just holding g4
keeping black in the driver's seat as
far as the pressure on the Kings side
the one issue I will say that black
might happen if the Queen's get trained
Oh Bishop c4 trying to over overload the
Queen from guarding g2 that was scary
for a second I was like where's that
Queen going
but yeah Knight f1 not a little take if
you take okay there's not absolutely
nothing there for her black if you don't
take now the Knights coming into f5 and
d6 is hanging OH
d6 now not now because Bishop takes h3
but it will be hanging in in some line
so you took careful the corners gonna
open the position if he gets e4 though
and the rook and Bishop meet for a date
on g2 White's got problem that is so
Queen e1 yeah I thought when you went to
peep smasher 9,000 thanks for
subscribing buddy rook f1 takes up 3
we're gonna get Queen she's free now I
think and white still has some tactics
to worry about but you were about to say
one thing black has to worry about is
his own King because he's played h5 and
I agree that's the tactical worry for
black here oh he missed Bishop c4
skewering bleedin truck Sergei just lose
eyes damn we're still folks in the game
and car was a 43 seconds in the end oh
my gosh I that's what that's my job is
to focus on time and I and I did I drop
the ball wow that was hit carro striking
back with revenge like alright I'm tired
of this and let's let's put Princess
Leia cardiac end in her place again like
tactical maneuvering positions are gonna
favor hit car because he he figures out
the answer so quickly yeah car yakin you
know he's a he's a little more pensive
he's a little more take one more time
and that's not gonna work in his favor
as you have only a minute to play for
the whole game so yeah Cara a one game
with how much time is left 13 minutes
just under 13 minutes 12 minutes and 50
seconds officially hey Carlos sticking
with his guns sticking by his guns
sticking with his guns whatever you call
it but happy to play these b3 positions
I guess he's relying on experience over
theoretical objectivity right he knows
that these be three lines of course
OTB are not something he would play
against Sergei but he also placed these
be three positions so much in Bullitt
he's not gonna go away from it
Thanks an Adam's son six for subscribing
on Twitch really appreciate it
alright so there's gonna be a problem
the d3 square that's the first thing I
noticed that scores a little bit soft
right now so black can consider going c4
at some moment yep and Bishop you know
just because pawn f2 is a little bit
vulnerable as well you have okay d4 yeah
that's weird the C file owned by me
right
yeah when coming to d3 I thought okay no
he's he's a little more he's gonna fight
for the C far but this Bishop is a
monster for the rest of the game here
hitting the C 2 square it's a monster
but doesn't do anything is the question
well here he plays BC - what's a queen
takes b6 at night
rook a six maybe sure up the queen no
the bish was on f1 so he that was
strange
oh well okay oh no he went Bishop f1
you're right yeah no no he didn't no the
was already an f1 anyway that
looks like a blunder I know or should I
thanks for the sub really appreciate it
thanks to everybody who's tuning in
right now on Twitch and Chester comm TV
all you subscribers and premium members
we appreciate it all right so Hikaru is
gonna continue to gang up on this a4
pawn as a target right with the bishop
what is Sergei doing here
I guess he's I guess he's just uh I
guess he's fine just playing tickle I'm
gonna sit with the King on the Kings
side but look at my time again notice
hit Carlos striking back and just
speeding up putting putting Sergei under
serious pressure
ooh I love d5 d5 and d6 everybody the
pawn couldn't be taken because of
discovered checks against the King by
the bishop well could have but I guess
this Knight takes d5 was perfectly
adequate cuz the e6 you just ignore it
but yeah it's not a position you really
like to have this black because look at
the pawn chain right black's pawn c4 is
totally stopped the Bishop III is a
really stupid looking piece it's like
how did I get there yep and
unfortunately for black you know that
with that stop in his tracks and you
know you can just the knight was on c3
it just
game over promise night they get to see
through too easily so he sacrificed open
up the bishop make sure he can get the
bishop bail but Sergei getting under
time pressure again puts us in a
position where you see why Nakamura is
known for what he is known everybody yes
it's been a close interesting game but
the difference in terms of how they got
here this is why he Cara wins bullet
games because he's up on time when it
matters so once again I spoke too soon
about kuryakin's bullet prowess I know
you did the right thing you you you
acted at the moment and you pointed out
what was happening and you created drama
but yeah hey Cara Nakamura shutting the
door with just under 10 minutes now back
up by two games it's not over yet but
cardiac end is is getting close to two
must-win right here right now and it's
linked to slowly so and right now it's
okay obviously he's getting you know got
over a minute on the clock after 10
moves but he's for the most I wasn't
playing way too slowly and he's just
pick up the pace
he needs to play better he needs to play
faster and you know he needs to apply
some pressure rather than be the one
who's getting squeezed because last time
with black definitely don't work out in
his favor right now it's you know this
is you know in his wheelhouse he plays
like this all the time in classical game
there's nothing easier to think about
rook d1 rooks he won he went 94 they all
these moves make perfect sense he just
needs to trust himself and he's an
obviously an amazing chess player and he
look at his move f5 it's not a movie you
really want to play as black so take
advantage of it Sergei like you know you
know structurally what and why that's it
not the best option often okay somehow
something's coming that's a nice move
though I think but Knight f4 yeah but
he's gonna take it open the light
squares right can this work maybe it's
not maybe it's not as good as I
initially thought I would might be three
to go to c5 I mean you you can also play
rook to e1 now Knight be threes even
more of a threat with the rook on the
deck file but yeah so black goes Knight
d4 not weird okay maybe three comes in
95 probably trade e5 and then 5 and if
Queen if I go Knight a5 that a5 would
have been a nice move there
I agree partner but ok this is
this is still fine fit well yeah and the
main thing everybody's attention here
favors white because black can never
take it without this e6 pawn becoming a
big weakness so yeah okay I'm starting
to like White's position more and more
yes he fought me to the d3 Bishop is
kind of irritating leap in dope but he
unpin it in fashion because Bishop d6
doesn't work
96 take take Bishop a3 something like
that right but I guess the a6 pawn falls
too in the end so that no you're right
no I had that slipped away there and hey
Carter
you know he's a gamesman he knows what's
at stake here he'll he's not gonna greet
anymore draws yep he's in the clock yep
as he should time to time to make your
opponent prove it I guess and again only
seven minutes left if this game takes
another minute or so off the clock off
of the total running game clock it's you
know you're getting into really
dangerous territory for karaoke and it's
pretty much over so wins happen quickly
in bullet and we have seen back-to-back
victories by people right as clock
expired and send it in overtime we
pretty much saw that in Geary vs. so but
the chances the chances are right now
getting worse for Kuryakin and he
offered a drawing a card declined it
despite being worse because you know the
time is more valuable than the point
actually even if the card ends up losing
this game if he can't waste another
minute and a half or you know how about
it's a great point it's more valuable
yep yeah now and then now absolutely no
winning chances for white because you
can't even get to that pawn net for so
you know Hickok was just going rook f6
ring up seven or if six drug of seven
okay yeah well Sergei should just do the
same and once the positions repeated
three times press the draw button and
the auto draw will claim it whether hit
Carver likes it or not so that's what he
should do
it's just take the draw but
but not sure all right your car will go
rook f6 after another 20 seconds so yeah
it's like a NFL game you know you just
wait milk the clock out and then you go
okay Hikaru politely agrees to a draw
right away there instead of other one by
repetition so maybe Sergei figure it out
he just needs to click the draw button
ah that's true and we're back in our be
three territory so it's different this
time okay he went g6 if you say if you
went d4 d5 and Bishop b5 and you have
some problems the e5 square now we see
the pawn structure change such that
black has taken towards the center by
the same time White's Bishop on b2 is
doing very well competing at the bishop
on g7 yep so well again though it's a
karo sticking but was sticking by what
he knows he can play quickly he's
probably played these positions just you
know I'll probably say an exaggerated
number right now but thousands of times
I mean he has played these positions as
white in terms of the amount of online
chess he has played so very comfortable
playing these b3 structures
yeah and look at Kuryakin he keeps going
for this idea eventual breakthrough with
pawn a4 and so he can take on b2 he can
play for right okay he does exactly that
yep if you ever take on a4 for white
you've just totally ruined your pawn
structure on the queenside with I have
two sets of my slave not to such two
isolated pawns yeah Carl played before
there and then kind of gave a gave a
frowny face well look at the knight
right that's a we Natalie look the thing
is a white also can put that Bishop on
c6 it's always something to keep in mind
yep and you know you for blacks
perspective the knight is just better
than the bishop that's always a good
from White's perspective okay if you go
and now that Bishop is grab your truck
well plus if you can get the bishop to
c6 okay there's chances the bishop can
be undermined with ideas like e6000 can
mrs. Bishop takes a four that's huge and
you can see he just blundered the pawn
that's not a good look not a good look
well I don't know how that pawn makes
any progress but it's still at least a
carton which exactly it's not even about
the wind at this point it's about
eliminating cardiac ins chances to win
and with it almost officially securing
the match
so yeah I mean this is where this this
type of format is different than what
you would normally see in normal over
OTB classical chess you're just asking
what's the evaluation is it a win draw
or loss right in this situation you're
competing against the time the row
that's running out and unfortunately for
Sergei a draw is not gonna be enough so
yeah I mean to make makes crazy stuff
here even g5 maybe it's good for black
he's got to try to do something over
here on the Kings side
yeah and he's acknowledging that white
wall white is up a pawn I can't really
do anything right the all the piece of
hide together shoutout route coder
thanks for subscribing
oh that Queen just got in yeah this wean
is in the eagle has landed
f4 comes and it's over yeah I think
hurry I can probably just lose it on
time and he does just that so 40 seconds
to zero second with that we're gonna
officially say that hit Cara Nakamura he
will be moving on to face Magnus Carlsen
on January 3rd in the speech as champion
finals there's just not enough time not
enough tone for a car y'all can to come
back you only well they remembered
there's a 960 game that's untime so if
Cara can win this game very quickly then
he he's got another at least one more
bullet game and then they can win that
he needs to doesn't went off but he's
got away this one in in a devastatingly
fast fashion yes it's not looking good
to say the least
yep and we've seen this you know this
ain't our first rodeo in this yelling
and Hikaru learned from his first lesson
if you just joined us Corey Aachen won
the first game of the matches white in a
structure very similar similar to this
where Hikaru had kind of overextended
the F pawn and created some weaknesses
and carry Aachen has gone back to this a
couple times but Hikaru has learned from
his mistakes and not repeated that same
positional mistake and and has sensed
him much better on the black side of
these London's and and I think he's
doing just fine here as well well I
think like as maybe even better here
comes F 3 F 3 squares a problem
93 is a problem lots of good stuff here
for black and yeah the thing that
whitens our target is the defy pawn but
you know to wait
huh that's strange yeah now why maybe
have some winning chances we can gobble
up the f3 pawn but hey Carla thinks
it'll be too slow he's gonna try to
bring the Queen in for some mate some
maid action over here
so h4 okay green d3 play instead waive
rook takes c3 rotate or the Queen 93 is
Queenie a checkmate was in New York
Mikey slice just subscribe shout out to
Mikey slice make sure you check out his
twitch channel and all that is Mikey
slice
I think White's better here I think I'm
like yeah I think white is better mainly
because there's no mating then and that
F pawn is is eventually gonna be a
target they're on f3 but and yeah as you
said Queen B 5 hits d5 but the real
looking now now we trained those Queens
trade the Queen's trade on e4 put the
knight on e3 and get your king active
yep these King comes III yeah Oh even
better
how are you good thanks for subscribing
ah not enough time well actually no if
he wins this in the next like 2 seconds
then gotta win this in the next 30
seconds and I don't think he's going to
and it Cara's 42 seconds so it's not
gonna happen
yep
well super super interesting stuff still
super instructive chess here by both
players regardless of the match result
and this was this was a nail-biter I
mean I mean this match was tied with
with 15 minutes left Robert and even
though that that brings us to the end of
the one one portion one more chess960
game after this and then postgame
interviews let's see what both a caro
and Sergei have to say for themselves
but either way this was this was exactly
what the doctor ordered when we
predicted this match was pretty much a
toss-up I think I think we got our
money's worth yeah I mean really great
performance by cardiac in you know he's
gonna end up losing this match is a
pretty close score I think that it was
quite an even match for the most part
just a critical moments Sergei did not
use this time very well he you know you
can't go down on the clock against a car
like he has been and he carved you know
all credit to him he's a genius at
defensive resourcefulness the guy just
like knows how to save him so we call
cardiac in the Minister of Defense
because of how it played against Carlson
in the World Championship match but I
think in online chess you know is there
anyone more resourceful in a Cara
Nakamura no and and no one who makes
those resourceful decisions as quickly
anyway right and that's really the key
because time is of the essence time is
part of the game and and that's that's
what a Cara Nakamura does better than
anybody really now the balance of chess
and that time is is what makes the
difference really between Magnus Carlsen
being the favorite I think to win the
final against the Cara Nakamura but job
either way hikaru has offered a draw to
Sergei he knows it's over
Sergei not taking it wanting to try to
push on a little further given that he
is or he was at least the only one he
was in the driver's seat but now now
what's going on now
now I don't really know if the car was
gonna take the drug well it's still a
draw still a draw but bring bring the
blockaded the dark screws we've
highlighted the dynamics of those types
of endings where you have a bishop can't
attack the dark squares and here we go
our last chess960 battle my friend and
what do we got well the car gets the
white pieces we have both bishops in the
corners
was seeing that double feed keto or
double long diagonal action and already
white and black in both Castle kingside
if they want that's the cam roughly just
swap places something to keep in mind a
seven was falling but anymore but I
guess cardiac and didn't want to play a
six because it might weaken the b6
square and there's a very principled
player he is he's just saying you know
I'll keep it protected and the night
would be files not really doing anything
just leave leave it there
shoutout to Morecambe who just
subscribed thank you for your support
lots of night actually a lot of night
online as soon as we get the king's
castle this will no longer look like a
chess960 cave this is some sort of
symmetrical english gone boring pretty
sure that was tied alive bought vinick's
autobiography there's a gun pouring gone
boring but robert never shut his window
title of your autobiography with all the
horns with here in New York I shot my
windows just you know when it's just New
York yeah no I'm just kidding alright
well like I said symmetrical English
gone boring whether the Kings have
castled or not and that's what we're at
I don't think it's more though I think
that whites in big trouble because we're
double seems like an extreme seems like
a seems like a little bit a little bit
harsh because even with light-square
checks I mean the king could run and now
he's Castle there's I forgot you could
castle yeah yeah I was like okay you're
kings cut off Kings I'm really square
but castling that saves the day yeah
okay you're I agree with you well so
what are the questions we're gonna have
for these two gentlemen located directly
above us on our stream I mean obviously
hit karo he lost his first game but then
he he he bounced right back as far as
the five-minute portion goes I think a
tale of really high quality Chester
mcaro and maybe a couple missed
opportunities by Sergei that eventually
came back to bite him because he did
indeed bring the match to a tie at some
point in the bullet yeah and I was
thinking that Sergei was playing better
earlier in the match I thought that he
was I think I said this you know a
couple hours ago that
based on the play I thought that Sergey
should had a superior score but
unfortunate for him at some critical
moments he just couldn't make it happen
yeah well we saw you know a couple of
rec endings not converted and we'll ask
him how he felt about time pressure was
there just a certain amount of nerves or
maybe maybe feeling like he rushed some
decisions because of his fear of getting
under further time pressure cuz what you
and I were critical of a couple of
moments where he missed wins I mean
there was that efore move in that end
game right where they drew two moves
later and he was winning right there was
the Lucena endgame so again not taking
away any anything from the Cara Nakamura
who's doing exactly what we kind of
thought he would do those are the things
that I think I wonder if wonder where
Sergei felt that he was just not
managing his time well right and that's
the mystery of time management taking
your time right management is knowing
when to do it right you're gonna get a
time pressure but that doesn't mean
there aren't critical moments where you
need to find the best move and maybe
when you let those practical fears of
don't get under anymore time pressure
allows you to move too quickly when you
maybe miss a chance to win right and
we're gonna have to ask
hikaru you know what he plans on
changing this year against Magnus right
he lost that match last a little bit
absolutely speaking of critical moments
and wondering why wins is this kind of
like the other one we're just talking
like those seen a game you know Black
was up a pawn clearly earlier and now
Black is intense a draw I don't know yep
well either way the match is over
officially we come to a close with the
score you see above us 16 and a half to
13 and a half in favor of the American
as soon as we can let the players know
that we are here and it's not a
shout-out to Z Fox who just subscribed
forgot to shout it out hey Carl can you
hear us
yeah I can hear you Sergey are you there
can you hear us you can hear us we can't
hear him we can't hear you yet is your
microphone unplugged we can't hear you
so maybe your mic check if your
microphone is plugged in or maybe did
you mute your mic in the sound at the on
the computer possibly you did okay well
hey karo congratulations big win 16 and
a half 13 1/2 final score and you are
moved
on to the finals a lot to talk about in
this one there was a moment there where
Sergei brought the pressure and and won
a couple games in a row and bullet and
what what did you what do you feel you
changed in that moment it from our
perspective you seem to speed up and
really get back to putting putting
pressure on Sergei as far as time goes
there were several games that ended with
you being up nearly 40 seconds there was
that a bit of a kind of a jolt in you
and you started playing even faster and
trusting yourself even more in that
moment you know I mean the first thing
is that that game I mean the first one I
lost not the second one but first my
loss was I mean we're basically just
repeating and then I just played this
King e7 who which is a huge blunder and
Sergei didn't see c5 but 85 actually was
was good enough so I didn't have a
simple move that I could play we
shouldn't drop the piece so yeah I mean
that started and then yeah the next
thing was not very good but but I just
felt like I played pretty pretty fast
throughout the bullet um I mean I I felt
that action the bullet especially I
didn't really convert a lot of positions
I should have but still I mean obviously
I was ahead you also joked out in in the
blitz and you grabbed a lead there
obviously Sergei has been has been used
to having big advantages against the
other two people he beat to reach at
this point so you stuck with this b3
approach can you give us a little bit of
insight of what your thoughts were on
being consistent playing positions that
you've played a lot in online blitz and
bullet and what your thoughts were in
facing Sergei blitz yeah I mean the
first thing is that it's probably the
same thing that I set for the match
against Fabiano I mean I basically was
gonna start with that and if it didn't
really work then I'd probably switch to
something else and um you know I think
against Fabiano also I think I lost the
first game with black just like in this
match and then second game I won a game
with b4 which I probably shouldn't have
and I felt like in this match was kind
of same thing the second game I won
which realistic I shouldn't have won if
I don't win that game there probably
were to change my strategy
but after that um I mean the match is
pretty balanced throughout I was just a
game here there so I didn't really see a
point switching it up and you know the
bullet I could have probably done
something different but but really when
you've been doing that for three hours
it's kind of hard to want to switch
right hey car I'm a question about your
initial strategy you played in early f5
in that first game were you trying to be
aggressive just to see the shape that
there's a London system just to see the
shape that Sergei was in see how the
match would go for you I'm trying to
remember that position right
but the reason Robert highlighted it is
because you face that same sort of g3
London with the 90s won't worry God is
like queen bee or queen seed and then he
was able to get rookie yeah I mean I I
thought the position was fine it's just
I was a little bit too slow oh my god
behind on the clock in that game and I
mean I wanted to try and play
aggressively and I thought f5 was flying
but I just didn't really find a plan and
then I mean the game was again very
balanced but I kind of let my time get
too low and I just made a simple blunder
and after that I was just just over
Sergei can you are as your mic back on
can you hear us now
it's the muting no I don't know why
we've lost a sound for some reason
well don't worry we can at least say hi
to you in the fans per game if you can
if you can find a way to unmute your
mind that would be great but it I don't
know if you muted it in your task trade
down with the volume mixer if you can
try one more time but well obviously a
card if this was a back and forth match
there like you said just came down to a
game or two and in the in the last match
you had with Magnus it was also very
close there and you did eventually have
the edge and bullet heading and heading
into the finals now it's a repeat of
what the fans saw and what many of the
fans wanted is it is a rematch Nakamura
Carlsen give us a little bit of your
thoughts on on how maybe you plan to
approach this match with Magnus it is
Magnus Carlsen but how do you plan to
approach this match maybe a little
differently and what are your thoughts
there yeah I mean I think I mean the
match with Magnus was was not really
close in the end but I think if I had
perhaps used more time in certain
situations or dragged a few games out
longer I mean probably score score in
the margin went to Venice wide so I
think the main thing probably to take
away from that is that I'm probably
gonna try and play this much more in a
match sort of situation whereas last
when I felt the kind of you know I just
if I was winning here or losing him I
tried to end it as fast as possible um
and I mean I think that cost me um
nevertheless I mean I thought that match
was was quite closer as one game I think
where I had won it would have been like
two or three in a row and then I might
gone on a roll but nevertheless it's
gonna be interesting and I'm looking
forward to playing max again because
that's it's always always fun playing
that's
well the fans are too Sergei I'm really
it's unfortunate we we ran into this
technical difficulty but you look good
if that's if that accounts for anything
so thanks for that
and obviously congratulations on playing
such great chess
getting here and we know today didn't
work out the way you want it but the
match was tied with 15 minutes to go
really and bullet and we thought we
thought you you were you were playing
very well so asked one more time is your
mic on can we hear you I don't think so
okay well asking yes or no questions
that way he just shake his head yes or
no questions well okay do you do you
feel do you how did you feel you I don't
know how to ask yes or no questions I'm
I wasn't prepared for this Robert
anyway well the truth is we're gonna let
you both go we know it's very late for
Sergei in Russia
hikaru again you're in London so let's
you let you get back to it there
congratulations for both you happy New
Year and hey Karl we will see you on the
other side of 2018 early 2018 for your
match with Magnus and thank you both
again yeah thanks alright well there we
go we we actually have the bracket there
in front of us not officially updated
robber but we know now Hikaru Nakamura
will be facing off against Magnus
Carlsen as we said it will be on January
3rd no longer a question mark
it is Hikaru Nakamura and any any final
thoughts from you on what we expect to
see and what you think a car needs to do
to try to beat Magnus Carlsen yeah I
think I was a little harsh on the
players today just because you know he
expects so much out of them and I think
that Hikaru you know he said he was
sticking to his guns when he feared that
he was getting good results he stuck
with his b3 stuff I think he needs to
play a little bit more mainline things
especially against Magnus now of course
you know Magnus is the best player in
the world he's proven his dominance in
this format I mean he won the event last
year and he's been nothing short of him
absolutely outstanding this year but I
think that playing a little bit more
mainline stop playing as b3 stuff
because a certain point the lines are
easy to kind of prepare for not just
like in terms of long-term theory but in
terms of mentally like the mental
fortitude to resist and so I think he
just he'll switch it up
doubt helped me playing be three against
Magnus so frequently and I think he's
ready I mean he looked you know quite
convincing at a certain point in this
match me he lost that first game the
ability to bounce back as something that
should not be underestimated as an
important characteristic of a chess
player he's got the heart of a lion he's
you know a fierce competitor Sergei had
his chances today you know it's a shame
but for all his fans that he couldn't
get through but like I said the
resourcefulness of acara Nakamura is
probably second to none and on my chest
yeah obviously I agree and I think that
even though the big favorite is is
Magnus just based on what we've what we
all know we've we've seen in in terms of
when these guys have gone up against it
before but before I let you go obviously
we're super excited for January 3rd
everybody who's still with us thank you
for all your support on Twitch on chess
TV mark your calendar January 3rd Magnus
Carlsen dakara Nakamura it's the finals
people predicted but that doesn't mean
it's not the finals people wanted and
today was super close for for Ricardo
just kind of barely getting by there by
Sergei but this this will be exciting
and I agree with you I think one thing I
will say again I think that Hikaru has
gotten good positions against Magnus in
there over the board tournaments I mean
he had a winning position in London
right just just literally two weeks ago
Hikaru Nakamura was winning on the board
against Magnus and and then really miss
played the same game thank you distant
fire for the sub so I agree I think that
if Hikaru is prepared to play main lines
and willing to do that to get theory
he's proven he can get good positions
against Magnus right so maybe that's
exactly what he needs to do and on top
of what he said he criticized himself
for maybe of resigning too quickly in
some of the games last year against
Magnus and and maybe he needs to have a
little bit more of a stubborn approach
this year yeah absolutely all right well
thank you everybody again we're gonna
leave you with one final shout out to
our our sponsors of course masterclass
funding bringing you bringing you lots
of stuff to the chess world this year
helping support the speech Chess
Championship and bringing Garry Kasparov
to his first ever masterclass course
we're gonna check in one more time with
the trailer that we showed to start this
broadcast and encourage all of you to
head over there sign up for his course
it's awesome I've checked it out it's
really interesting they really do put
together an awesome product over there
so if you're a tournament player looking
to get better that's what you need to do
Robert thanks for flying alongside me
buddy and I'll see you next time
always a pleasure I'm trying to come up
with the comprehensive picture that will
be helpful for you to become a better
chess player and even a better decision
maker check I want to show you the
ultimate deflection the ultimate
sacrifice so here we are white pawns see
their advanced a7 b6 c6 the sugars paint
all working white favor but this one
problem is check if white King goes on a
six then geometry works in black they
work we need to check and it will be a
perpetual white King will not escape do
you see any way to prevent black Queen
from attacking our King and forcing draw
has it work 25 and that's one of the
lessons of this endgame